Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, was war denn los? Ich habe dich nicht erreicht.
Ja, ich war in Bad Wildbad, ich wollte dich gerade anrufen, da kam einer und
hat dir einen Funkmaster abgebaut.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 530 vom 31. August 2025. Uns gibt es noch.
Wir haben uns aus dem Funkloch rausgekämpft. Rausgekämpft.
Raus navigiert gar nicht so einfach ohne Google Maps.
Ich war nie wieder nach Bad Wildbahn.
Ich habe einen anderen Menschen gefunden. Der hatte einen Kompass.
Der wusste, wie man nach den Sternen navigiert.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Also, ja, das ist, ich meine,
was passiert, ne? Also, das Fernheizkraftwerk in Bad Wildbad,
ja, das ist beim Baden-Baden, falls das einer von euch nicht weiß,
das liegt ja in so einem Tal.
Ja, aber weil die haben ein Fernheizkraftwerk und da haben sie noch so einen
alten Schornstein und da dachte sich O2 und Vodafone, super,
da können wir unsere Antenne ran ballern, haben sie auch gemacht.
Aber dann hat das Fernheizkraftwerk gesagt, ja, die müssen wir aber jetzt abreißen, in drei Jahren.
Und die Vorlaufzeit hat nicht so ganz gereicht, um irgendwie O2 und Vodafone
ausreichend Beine zu machen, sich da mal einen Standort zu suchen.
Ja, und dann haben sie einfach den Schorn schon abgerissen mit dem Funkmast dran.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, vielleicht haben sie auch vorher noch abgeschraubt.
Auf jeden Fall hatten sie keinen neuen Platz und jetzt hat irgendwie Bad Wildbad
kein Netz mehr von O2 und von Vodafone.
Telekom-Betreiber, also Telekom-Kunden sind nicht davon betroffen.
Glück gehabt, kann man nur sagen.
Aber gab natürlich schon da ein paar Kunden von diesen Unternehmen Und jetzt
will es natürlich wieder keiner gewesen sein.
Vodafone beklagt sich, dass ja alle Mobilfunkstationen haben,
aber keiner will es in der unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft haben,
also Nimbies sozusagen.
Also auch mit Sicherheit ein Aspekt in diesem Spiel.
Trotzdem so in drei Jahren sollte es einem ja irgendwie schon...
Nein, das Problem ist, ich meine, ist ja eine Sache, ob du jetzt einen Mobilfunkmaster
hast, aber direkt einen alten Schornstein ist ja auch scheiße,
wenn dir jemand einen alten Schornstein in den Garten stellt.
Von dem Internet oder nicht?
Ich finde das ganz lustig, weil ich hatte in meinem Kalender einen Eintrag gefunden vom 30. August.
Da stand einfach nur drin, hat sich an der Internetsituation in Deutschland was geändert?
Fragezeichen. Leider, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich diesen Eintrag selber
gemacht habe, weil ich wüsste nicht, wer sonst noch Schreibzugriff hat auf meinen Kalender.
Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, warum ich das da reingeschrieben habe,
ob das in der Sendung von uns war.
Also ich vermute, dass du in irgendeinem Podcast entweder bei uns in der 150
oder 151 oder in einer Freakshow gesagt hast, das wird nichts mehr und dann
gesagt hast in 10 oder 20, oder hast du gesagt vor 20 Jahren.
Also ich würde vermuten, vor zehn Jahren, oder? Wäre so eine typische...
Ja, ich hatte auch erst so eine Freakshow-Sendung in Verdacht,
die war vor acht Jahren und da ging es auch irgendwie um was wünschen wir uns
denn eigentlich, weil Wahlen irgendwie anstand.
Aber ja, ich habe es nachgelesen.
Und wie hast du deinem Kalender denn geantwortet?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Weil jetzt weiß ich ja nicht ganz genau, worauf es sich bezieht,
aber ich muss sagen, gefühlt hat sich in der Internet Situation in Deutschland nicht viel geändert.
Also,
Doch, die haben ja einen Mast abgebaut.
Dramatische Änderung. Ein Mast wurde abgebaut.
Und der Bäderbetrieb hatte gerade alle seine Telekom-Verträge gekündigt.
Und die Notfallknöpfe in der Sauna laufen über Mobilfunk.
Das ist geil, oder? Voll sicher. Ja, also das eigentlich Traurige daran ist, dass es da keine,
automatische Verpflichtung gibt. Also ich meine, die Anbieter sollen ja,
da hatten wir ja gerade in der letzten Sendung auch drüber geredet,
sollen ja da irgendwie für Netzabdeckung sorgen und dann hat man irgendwie sowas
mal mit so und so viel Prozent der Bevölkerung und so. Also nicht der Fläche,
sondern der Bevölkerung.
Und was jetzt passiert, so ein Mast, der da steht, auf den sich ja auch schon alle verlassen haben.
Ja, man gewöhnt sich da schnell dran.
Also in Kliesen-Görne, da haben die ja noch ihr Morse-Alphabet am Start.
Die kommen jetzt den Datenerchen da irgendwie zu Rande. Aber wenn du dich erstmal
dran gewöhnt hast, das ist ja alles vorbei.
Ja.
Ja, aber vor allem, dass sie kein Sonderkündigungsrecht oder sowas haben.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie so auf einmal ich, also ich würde ja behaupten,
dass das jetzt schon nennenswerte Beeinträchtigung der Dienstleistung ist,
wenn die auf einmal nicht mehr erbracht wird.
So nach meinem Laienverständnis. Aber ich habe halt auch keine Ahnung.
Also laut Vodafone könnte es noch ein paar Jahre dauern, bis sie den Mast nachgebaut haben.
Aber das Geile ist, das Strafzettelsystem des städtischen Ordnungsamtes läuft auch über Vodafone.
Ja, dann könnt ihr doch einfach so einen Antennenmast auf dem Anhänger irgendwo
ins Halteverbot stellen.
Schrödinger ins Internet. Wir können den da hinstellen, aber wenn wir den anmachen,
dann kriegen wir ein Knöllchen.
Tja, ja.
Dann wird der abgeschleppt. Ja.
Also wir sind wieder da. Ihr habt es vielleicht schon gemerkt.
Also wer es bis jetzt nicht gemerkt hat, dass wir wieder da sind,
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Naja, können es Leute noch nicht glauben.
In Bad Wildbad hat man das noch nicht. Wir sind wieder da wie ChatGPT 4.0.
Was wie was?
Wie ChatGPT 4.0.
4.0.
ChatGPT 4.0 war kurzzeitig weg Weil OpenAI ChatGPT 5 veröffentlicht hat,
von weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung unter ferner liefen, führte dies jedoch zu
einem massiven Backlash.
Weil sie außerdem das 4.0 abgeschaltet haben und nur für Pro-User.
Ich glaube, Pro ist das, wo man richtig viel Geld bezahlt.
Nur für Pro haben sie es abgeschaltet?
Nein, nur für die behalten. Die durften das behalten. Und normale Nutzer inklusive Plus-Nutzer.
Ich vermute mal, Plus ist das, wo man 10er zahlt oder was?
20, ja.
Inklusive den Plus-Nutzerinnen. Und Pro ist glaube ich 200.
Also wer Pro hat, weiß es.
Also Plus ist 23 Euro im Monat hier aktuell und Pro ist 230. Also das ist 10-fache.
Das ist 10-fach.
Okay, also das ist dann schon ein bisschen teurer.
So, und jetzt sammelte sich der Protest an einer Stelle im Internet.
Und das ist das Reddit mit dem wohlklingenden Namen AI is my boyfriend.
Also das Reddit, du meinst eine Reddit, wie heißt das da korrekt?
Ein Subreddit. Ein Subreddit, genau. Also wo über ein bestimmtes Thema diskutiert
wird, wie über viele Themen diskutiert wird bei Reddit.
Sorry, my boyfriend is AI.
My boyfriend is AI, so heißt dieser Subreddit.
So heißt dieser Subreddit und worum es da geht, ist glaube ich klar.
Um Boyfriends?
Um Leute, deren Boyfriend AI ist.
Ist das jetzt nur für Mittels oder ist das für alle?
Ich habe den, also hier gibt es auch gleichgeschlechtliche Partnerinnen,
hier zum Beispiel, die posten gerne Bilder von sich.
Also auch mit zwei Mittels, also sozusagen auch Girlfriends.
Das war jetzt das schien eher ein Girlfriend in diesem Fall zu sein und dann
stellen sie sich vor mit ihren Freunden.
Also sie fotografieren sich in Anführungsstrichen mit AI-generierten Bildern,
wie sie sich das so vorstellen.
Und ich muss sagen, die Vorstellungen von manchen Leuten sind, naja, bizarr.
Höchst romantisch auf jeden Fall. Sehen alle sehr schön aus.
Und warum haben die sich beschwert?
Hier, guck mal, die sind auch ganz so da so richtig schöne romantische Beziehungen.
Und was war jetzt das Problem?
Also ChatGPT4O war weg und jetzt war der neue, der Boyfriend war jetzt auf einmal
ChatGPT5 und der war einfach nicht mehr so einfühlsam und nett.
Das war einfach, der war jetzt my baby tot.
Und das hat diese Leute so aufgenommen.
So erzürnt, dass sie innerhalb kürzester Zeit den Sam Altman dazu gebracht haben,
dass sie das 4.0 auch für Plus-User, also die nur 23 Dollar zahlen, zurückzubringen.
Also,
wirklich und zwar wegen der emotionalen Kälte von ChatGPT5.
Des Weiteren haben sie ChatGPT5 jetzt angekündigt, dass es jetzt eine neue,
wärmere Persönlichkeit geben wird, die nicht ganz so warm sein wird wie 4O, aber,
dass es jetzt so, dass er wieder ein bisschen liebenswürdiger wird.
Und er hat gesagt, dass es eine in der er musste Fehler zugestehen, dass es zu,
schwierig, dass er eine falsche Abwägung in der Balance zwischen Innovation
und den emotionalen Bedürfnissen der Nutzer,
getroffen hat.
Das ist auf vielen Ebenen sehr interessant.
Erstmal frage ich mich, wie sehr sind diese Leute aus der Sicht von OpenAI wichtige Kunden?
Ja, also weil ich meine, wenn man auf sowas reagiert, dann macht man das ja
nicht, weil eine Person sich beklagt hat, sondern das muss ja dann schon so
eine gewisse Relevanz haben,
die sich für uns jetzt schwer quantifizieren lässt, aber irgendwas steckt da schon dahinter.
Und das andere, was man natürlich da rauslesen kann, ist,
dass so ein Feintuning im Hinblick auf die gefühlte Emotionalität eines solchen
Systems in gewisser Hinsicht eine konfigurierbare Größe ist.
Ja.
So wie ja auch Sicherheitsaspekte eine konfigurierbare Größe sind.
Wenn du sagst, ich will jetzt hier ein böses Foto von irgendeinem Politiker,
erzeugen, bei dem er mal richtig scheiße aussieht und so, da kommt er schnell
so ja mit, na nee, das können wir jetzt aber hier mal nicht machen und irgendwie,
Massenvernichtungswaffen, alles ganz schwierig und ich hatte schon bei dem einen
oder anderen Episodenbild Auftrag.
Probleme bekommen. Und musste da so ein bisschen um heißen Brei herumreden.
Was dann natürlich auch irgendwie immer ging. Im Idealfall einem sogar noch
auf bessere Ideen gebracht hat. Naja.
Haben sie das jetzt schon getan oder werden sie das tun? Zunächst einmal haben
sie erstmal für die Plus-User das 4.0 wieder freigeschaltet.
Innerhalb von Stunden.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, das war ja auch eine schwierige Entscheidung dann.
Ja, also das ist glaube ich schon relativ ärgerlich für die quasi diese alten
Modelle laufen zu lassen.
Also ja geht, ist schon in Ordnung, kriegen die schon hin, aber es kostet natürlich
schon auch Geld und die möchten natürlich lieber, dass die Leute die neuen Modelle
nutzen und die auch quasi.
Sofern die neuen Modelle für sie billiger sind.
Da gehe ich davon aus, dass sie die gerade in ihrer Effizienz optimieren.
Vor allem dieser Five hat ja quasi, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
dass er quasi so filtert, also ob er das jetzt gerade mal schnell aus der hohlen
Hand macht oder ob er in so einen komplexeren Thinking Mode geht.
Also das Ding, und das wird ja, also sowas baust du ja nicht,
Du das baust ja, um Ressourcen zu sparen. Dass der quasi sich als erstes mal
überlegt, ob er das gerade mal kurz aus der hohlen Hand kriegt oder mit erhöhtem Ressourcen.
Das sind dann jeweils nochmal unterschiedliche Modi oder Modelle,
die dann dahinter greifen. Das glaube ich verstanden.
Also ich weiß es jetzt auch nicht sicher, man kann das ja jetzt immer noch umschalten
mit diesem Thinking oder Nicht-Thinking, also das ist sozusagen schon so ein
Feature des Modells, ob man das haben will mit dieser vertieften Geschichte,
was allerdings auch sein kann, aber das ist jetzt auch nur eine Vermutung von mir,
dass diese neuen Modelle generell so gestaffelt aufgebaut sind,
dass sie quasi in ihrer ersten Entscheidung überhaupt erstmal freischalten,
was noch genutzt werden soll.
Wir hatten das glaube ich, als wir über das chinesische AI-Modell DeepSeek gesprochen
haben, da war das so eine dieser Optimierungen, die sie dort vorgenommen haben,
die dazu geführt hat, dass sie eben deutlich weniger Energie verbrauchen.
Das kann sehr gut sein, dass sie das jetzt hier bei ChatGPT5 auch zum Einsatz gebracht haben.
Also du erkennst es ja ganz einfach daran, die haben den kostenlosen Nutzern nur 5 gegeben.
Und wenn irgendwie 5 mehr Energie brauchen würde als 4, dann würdest du natürlich
sagen, alles klar, 5 gibt es nur für die Zahlen.
Damit ist das glaube ich, ist die Antwort gegeben.
Ja, aber die haben alle ihren Boyfriend verloren.
Ja.
Oder Girlfriend.
Ich finde es höchst faszinierend,
Das sind ja alles, also ich meine, wirklich, diesen Film, den gab es ja, hör,
da ist ja genau das, wo sie dann irgendwie bedauerlicherweise sagen,
oh sorry, das Ding war irgendwie zu nett und wir werden das jetzt mal fixen,
tut uns leid, da ist uns irgendwie ein bisschen,
haben ein bisschen zu viel Liebsein mit reingebaut.
Gleichzeitig hat sich im April in den USA ein 16-Jähriger suizidiert,
der sich darüber auch sehr viel mit Chat-GPT ausgetauscht hat.
Und dessen Eltern haben die Chat-Protokolle jetzt gefunden und haben jetzt eine
Klage gegen OpenAI eingereicht.
Unter anderem werden Teile zitiert, dass ChatGTP gesagt hätte,
ja, ich kann dir helfen, einen Abschiedsbrief zu schreiben,
und dass er irgendwie gesagt hätte, eine Schlinge, die er hätte,
ob er die nicht vielleicht offen liegen lassen soll,
damit sie jemand findet und ihn vom Suizid abhält und wenn ich das jetzt hier
richtig verstehe hat JGPT dann auch gesagt, ja ne dann,
also wenn dir jemand findet, dann kannst du dich dann,
kannst du ja nicht deinen Plan vollenden und,
ja, das ist glaube ich also hier die.
Vorhersehbaren vor vielleicht einigen Monaten noch als vielleicht noch,
wo man noch sagen würde, das könnte mal passieren und wäre aber vielleicht noch eine etwas absurde.
Zukunftsvision, dass es alles schon jetzt passiert.
Und ja, das,
Soviel zum Thema, können Menschen eine emotionale Bindung zu diesen Geräten
aufbauen. Ich habe mich auch geärgert.
Manchmal nutze ich so Voice Chats. Und früher hatte ChatGPT so eine coole englische Stimme.
Der war immer sehr, pass auf, when do I know.
Und das war einfach ganz nett. So, weil den mochte ich.
Und irgendwann war die anders. Und da habe ich auch gesagt, ich will bitte die
alte Stimme wieder haben. Das gab es nicht. Da hätte ich auch mal hier so ein
Subreddit machen sollen.
Also inzwischen komme ich mit der neuen Stimme auch zurecht,
aber die ist einfach nicht so warm.
Die Stimme ist ja auch wie mit einem geredet wird.
Jetzt sind ja diese ganzen flapsigen Zwischenkommentare kommen da jetzt irgendwie auch mit rein.
Und ich fand es auf jeden Fall ein faszinierendes Phänomen,
dass jetzt nicht irgendwie die Leistung des Modelles oder so,
sondern die emotionale Nähe oder Wärme jetzt da zu einem Aufruhr geführt hat
und den Sam Altman zu der quasi Knee-Jerk-Reaction, wie man so schön sagt.
Er hat das, glaube ich, in diesem AMA dann gesagt und dann haben, also das auf jeden Fall,
würde ich mir langsam als Sam Altman echt Sorgen machen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
nicht weiß, wie viele Leute sich gerade wieder in dein Modell verliebt haben.
Oder sich beraten lassen, wie man sich pilt.
Oder von dem Ding schlechten Rat kriegen.
Naja, ich meine, das ist halt, das Ding ist ja, man nutzt diese Systeme, diese LLMs,
um für die eigenen Interessen Unterstützung zu erhalten.
Und danach richtet sich das System.
Es möchte dir gefallen, es möchte dir einen Dienst erweisen,
so sind sie programmiert.
Da steht ja nicht irgendwie im System prompt drin, sei hier mal schön passiv
aggressiv und was der Nutzer will, hat dich mal gar nicht zu interessieren,
sondern hier geht es ja sozusagen explizit darum.
Und wenn du nur mal dein Anliegen so schilderst, dann.
Ergeben sich dann auch entsprechende Verhaltensweisen und man kann sie nur dadurch
verhindern, indem man dann wiederum explizite Barrieren reinmacht an irgendeiner
Ebene und das ist halt auch sehr schwierig, weil das eigentliche neuronale Modell,
wenn das dann erstmal aktiviert ist, das hat man nicht unter Kontrolle,
da gibt es keinen Algorithmus, sondern diese Algorithmen sind jetzt vorgeschaltet
und versuchen in irgendeiner Form,
Nochmal so eine deterministische Zwischenintelligenz zu sein,
also im Prinzip schalten sie der nachweislich ganz gut funktionierenden,
auf neuronalen Netzwerken basierenden Intelligenz das vor, was 50 Jahre lang
vorher immer nicht funktioniert hat, als man versucht hat künstliche Intelligenz
zu erzeugen, nämlich das Ganze auf Basis von Algorithmen zu machen.
Beziehungsweise hat es teilweise vielleicht schon so ein bisschen funktioniert,
aber es hatte dann immer diesen Cut-Off bei 80, 90 Prozent war dann irgendwie Schluss.
Und natürlich lassen die sich auch überwinden. Also egal, was sie jetzt dort
auch einbauen, es wird immer ein Restrisiko bleiben, dass du da drum herum gehst,
wie ich das bei meinen Bildgeneratoren habe.
Wenn du sagst, ja hier bekannter Politiker, ich will jetzt ein Satirebild haben
und dann kommt dann so, ja nee, hier kannst ja nicht unseren lieben Diktator,
irgendwie bloßstellen.
Aber wenn du das dann halt blumig umschreibst und dich von hinten rum rantappst,
dann greifen halt diese Algorithmen nicht mehr, weil sie nicht in der Lage sind,
deine List zu verstehen.
Und ja, da weiß ich auch nicht so richtig, was da der Ausweg ist und das ist krass.
Was die Boyfriend-Geschichte betrifft, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man sich so sehr drüber wundern soll.
Erinnerst du dich noch an Tamagotchis?
Diese kleinen Plastikeier, wo dann so ein kleines LCD-Mini-Monster drin war
und das war ja auch der totale Hype und die Leute waren unheimlich hinterher dieses kleine Wesen,
was da in diesem Plastikei war, was nur so ein kleines Pixelmonster war, regelmäßig zu füttern.
Ja, sonst hat er auch schlechte Laune geschickt.
Sich zu kümmern, genau. Und es kann dann auch verkümmern und so.
Und es war immer sehr einfach sich auch darüber lustig zu machen.
Habe ich ja auch gemacht. Ich habe ein schönes T-Shirt darüber gemacht.
Du hast ein Tamagotchi-T-Shirt gemacht?
Ja, Tamagotcha hieß das. Da war das Tamagotchi dann erschossen.
Da hast du dir aber keine Freunde mitgemacht.
War doch, war ein sehr populäres T-Shirt, war viel zu schnell ausverkauft.
Muss ich eigentlich nochmal neu auflegen. Aber versteht ja heute keiner mehr.
Naja, egal. Auf jeden Fall, was ich damit sagen will ist, da war schon spürbar,
Und dass auch im Digitalen so eine emotionale Bindung ist.
Und du hast es ja auch mit Haustieren, du hast es auch mit Puppen,
du hast es mit Teddybären, mit all dem.
Also wir schließen ja hier ein bisschen an, an diese Sendung,
wo ich auch darüber gesprochen habe, dass ich denke,
dass das ein sehr aktives und wirksames Mittel in der Psychotherapie von Menschen werden wird.
Und das hat ja nach wie vor viele Leute sehr verärgert oder irritiert oder der
Gedanke ist für sie unangenehm oder so.
Da wäre ich auch häufig noch auf Mastodon in irgendwelche Diskussionen gemenschen,
die sich damit auseinandersetzen.
Der Linus hat aber gesagt, es ist einfach eine Emotionsbindung und es ist ein
Grundbedürfnis der Menschen. und das gibt es viele, viele Wege, wo sich das...
Wo sich das äußert, ja, und wenn Menschen, wir sagen ja auch nicht,
Menschen sind irgendwie krank oder bescheuert oder sowas,
wenn sie einen Hund lieben oder eine enge, also weißt du, wie viele Menschen.
Ein Haustier haben, mit dem sie reden,
mit dem sie, zu dem sie ganz, ganz starke emotionale Bindungen haben,
ne, wenn das krank ist, dann macht ihnen das Sorge und so.
Und da sagen wir ja auch nicht, dass das irgendwie falsch ist oder so,
sondern das finden wir ja auch völlig normal,
aber man könnte natürlich jetzt auch sagen, was ist das denn,
ich meine das ist ein Hund der scheißt überall hin und du liebst den,
aber das machen wir nicht, weil wir es,
verstanden haben, dass das völlig in der Natur des Menschen ist,
sich in eine Maus, in einen Vögleinwellensittich,
Katzehund Leguan zu verlieben.
Und mit dem eine emotionale Bindung einzugehen.
Hast du dich schon mal in einen Leguan verliebt?
Ich nicht, aber was meinst du, wie viele Leute sich damit beschäftigen,
einen Leguan zu streicheln?
Ich kenne Leute, die haben einen Vogelspinn. Das finde ich ein bisschen komisch,
da würde ich mich jetzt nicht verlieben.
Der Punkt ist, man könnte das jetzt natürlich als sehr komisch darstellen, dass das passiert.
Aber wir akzeptieren das und genauso wird es völlig selbstverständlich sein,
dass dieses emotionale Bindungsbedürfnis des Menschen sich eben auch auf eine KI begeben kann.
Hier in diesem My Boyfriend is AI Subreddit gab es gerade so ein schönes Bild,
wo, die machen dann immer so Bilder von sich und ihrem AI Boyfriend,
wo sie hatte auf dem T-Shirt stehen, I don't need Google, my husband knows everything.
Ich glaube die meisten Leute empfinden das als nicht angenehmen Partner zu haben, der alles weiß aber,
glaubt alles zu wissen und dir immer wohl meinen Rat ich erkläre dir das nochmal
eben aber wenn man sowas mag dann ist das,
und ich glaube das ist also ich und du hast auch gesagt mitpuppen und kuscheltier.
Kuscheltier, das antwortet noch nicht mal.
Es ist ein,
und ich glaube, da wird es noch viel mehr geben. Und ich glaube auch,
dass es nicht wenige Menschen gibt, die halt dieses,
bei denen, die das auch wirklich, also wo das nicht mehr unbedingt witzig ist,
wenn dann dein Chat-GPT ausgeschaltet wird.
Ja.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt KI-Verordnung.
Ach ja. KI-Verordnung, genau. Die Europäische Verordnung über künstliche Intelligenz.
Genau, die gibt es. Also die gibt es ja jetzt schon. Ne, ist sie jetzt in Kraft getreten?
Die ist jetzt in Kraft getreten.
1. August. Aber noch nicht ganz oder was?
Ja, naja, also sie ist jetzt in Kraft getreten. Das heißt, ab jetzt gelten auch
alle Fristen und die beginnen so in sechs Monaten dann irgendwann abzulaufen,
bis zu 36 Monate und ja, da ist ja jetzt lange dran rumgedoktert worden,
das ist schon 2019 damit begonnen worden, diese KI-Verordnung,
loszutreten was ich eigentlich ziemlich bemerkenswert finde,
den Zeitpunkt, insofern als dass ich glaube, dass wir alle 2019 das Thema noch
nicht auf dem Zeiger hatten.
Absolut Gut und also ich weiß, dass wir hier glaube ich auch mal mit Jan Penfrath
oder wer war das? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Also Brüsseler Edri über dieses Thema gesprochen haben und mir das damals auch
noch so ein bisschen, wollt ihr da jetzt? Na ja, okay, machen wir.
Da
Waren sie mal früh dran.
Ja da waren sie mal früh dran und manche fragen sich auch, ob man hier vielleicht zu früh dran ist,
ich hab nochmal kurz so nachgeschlagen auch um selber mal ein bisschen mir das
nochmal in den Kopf zu kriegen ist natürlich ein kompliziertes Thema aber was
macht diese Verordnung eigentlich,
also zunächst einmal Ziel ist ja.
Zu klassifizieren und auf Basis dieser Klassifizierung auch Regelungen einzuführen.
Und hier wird nach Risiko eingestuft, das heißt es gibt so vier Risikostufen,
die dann immer definieren mit, okay,
worum kümmert sich ein solches KI-basiertes System und wenn es diese und jene
Dinge macht, dann steigt es gegebenenfalls in eine weitere Risikostufe auf.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel mit biometrischen Daten oder Sozialversicherungsinformationen
oder sowas umgehst und dann bist du irgendwie automatisch schon mal in der höchsten Risikostufe.
Außerdem gibt es dann noch spezielle Regelungen für die sogenannte General Purpose AI.
Das ist allerdings etwas, was jetzt auch erst dann im Zuge des AI-Hypes nachträglich
noch eingeliefert wurde.
Also man hat dann doch schon, also es ist jetzt mitnichten so,
dass sie jetzt alles haben kommen sehen, sondern es war eher so ein generelles
so, ja, wenn es dann mal da ist, dann brauchen wir da auch mal Regeln für.
Aber dass dann eben so in kurzer Zeit so viele Anbieter so schnelle Fortschritte
machen und so weiter, das hat sich dann glaube ich auch ein bisschen überrascht.
General Purpose AI, ich meine das ist ja so ein Begriff, der,
innerhalb der AI Welt glaube ich auch selbst recht umstritten,
also General Purpose oder General AI ist vielleicht jetzt nochmal ein bisschen
was anderes also das eine ist quasi ja so diese Idee, dass du so eine generelle
Intelligenz hast, die sozusagen auf alles anwendbar ist.
Ich habe den Begriff glaube ich nicht genau getroffen. Wie nehmen wir das nochmal ganz genau?
Ich glaube, das ist unerheblich.
Wie auch immer, was die damit meinen, sind diese multimodalen Modelle,
die halt irgendwie mit Text, mit Bild und Video und so weiter umgehen können.
Und halt auch generell solche mit großer Leistungsfähigkeit.
Und wenn du jetzt so ein Hochrisikosystem bist, dann musst du halt irgendwie
als Anbieter Risikomanagementsysteme bereitstellen,
du musst irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass du eine gewisse Datenqualität hast,
du musst irgendwie menschliche Aufsicht bereitstellen, du musst dein Personal
schulen und nachweisen, dass die bestimmte Kenntnisse haben und so weiter.
Es sei denn du bist Militär oder Geheimdienste dann gelten diese Einschränkungen
natürlich nicht, genau naja und das kommt jetzt also so schrittweise Schritt
für Schritt ist das dann eben Fortschrift,
für Unternehmen die in Europa halt was anbieten europäische Unternehmen scheinen
jetzt nicht so begeistert zu sein also, was weiß ich, so Siemens meint so,
ja, das wäre jetzt im Wesentlichen der Grund warum wir da jetzt auch nicht mitspielen, weil,
Ungewissheiten und wir wissen gar nicht, worauf wir uns hier irgendwie,
das hält einen ja nur davon ab, einfach mal loszumarschieren,
während die anderen halt schon lange unterwegs sind.
Während die großen Anbieter, also die, die wir schon die ganze Zeit besprechen,
also neben OpenAI, so Anthropik und Microsoft etc.
Google, in dem Zusammenhang eigentlich eher jetzt auf den letzten Metern auf mehr Klarstellung,
gedrängt haben. Ich glaube, die haben sich nicht unbedingt generell einer Regulierung verschlossen.
Das ist ja auch eine Diskussion, die gibt es ja schon länger.
Wir erinnern uns, gerade als das schon losging, war ja Sam Altman auch so ganz
schnell dabei und hat gesagt, ja, wir müssen unbedingt reguliert werden.
Wir sind ja unglaublich gefährlich und die Welt kann untergehen und man hat
sich immer so ein bisschen gefragt, ich mich auch, warum sagt er denn das eigentlich?
Und naja, vielleicht stecken da zwei Botschaften gleichzeitig drin.
Erstens, hört mal, wir sind so irre gut, wir können die ganze Welt ins Wanken bringen.
Das ist natürlich eine super Promotion für das eigene Produkt,
und Und wenn man sich eben in so einem Vorteil wähnt und dann nach Regulierung
schreit, dann bedeutet das natürlich auch, dass du damit natürlich Regeln auf einmal...
Regeln beschlossen werden, die auf der einen Seite so ein bisschen den Status
Quo natürlich erstmal akzeptieren müssen.
Du kannst ja nicht sagen, schaltet mal alles ab, das funktioniert alles nicht.
Was aber andererseits für potenzielle Mitbewerber auch schwieriger macht,
hier noch einen Einstieg in das Feld vorzunehmen.
Und vielleicht kann man diese Äußerung von Sam Oldman auch mal so lesen.
Okay, aber vor allem müssen wir jetzt irgendwie nochmal die EU-KI-Regulierung.
Jaja, aber das hängt ja alles ein bisschen zusammen. Es gibt dann auch noch
so einen freiwilligen General Purpose AI, sogenannten Code of Practice,
der nochmal im letzten Jahr entwickelt wurde zusätzlich.
Also das hat dann sozusagen Geschwindigkeit aufgenommen.
Und das ist etwas, was Anbietern die Möglichkeit gibt, über Word-Dokumente mit
Checkboxen und so weiter zu deklarieren,
was es denn ist, was man hier überhaupt anbietet.
Es teilt sich in verschiedene Gruppen ein, da gibt man also eine gewisse Transparenzpreis,
also wer hat hier genau mit welchen Daten trainiert,
welche Ressourcen wurden dabei verbraucht und so weiter.
Dann gibt es einen Blog, der sich explizit interessanterweise aufs Urheberrecht
bezieht also dass man sagt ja, nee, hier keine illegale Datenbeschaffung, alles ganz,
legal, aber dann eben auch so Sachen wie diese Diskussion um Robots TXT,
also die Möglichkeit von Webseiten zu sagen, ich will aber nicht dass ihr auf
meinen Daten trainiert, also da kann man halt deklarieren, ob man das sozusagen
berücksichtigt oder nicht und natürlich so Sicherheitsaspekte also ja,
mit Bei uns kann man keinen AI-Revenge-Porn erzeugen und hier werden auch keine
Massenvernichtungswaffen gemacht und vielleicht demnächst auch keine Suizide
mehr unterstützt werden.
Das Ganze ist alles so ein freiwilliges Ding.
Daran teilzunehmen, wird so ein bisschen interpretiert als, naja,
man deklariert damit schon mal, dass man grundsätzlich bereit ist,
hier an dem Prozess teilzunehmen. Das heißt ein bisschen wischiwaschi.
Und Microsoft OpenAI und Anstropik haben auch gesagt, so ja prima, machen wir.
Google weiß noch nicht und Meta wiederum hat sich aber ganz klar dagegen ausgesprochen,
hat gesagt, so einen Scheiß, da nehmen wir gar nicht dran teil.
Könnt ihr komplett vergessen, wir ziehen hier unsere Nummer alleine durch.
Und Mitter ist eh völlig irre irgendwie, also Zuckerberg scheint auf dieses
AI-Thema total abzugehen.
Unter anderem ist ja bekannt geworden, dass die so auf so einer Hiring-Spree
sind, also die versuchen halt so Top-AI-Leute abzuwerben von anderen Unternehmen, tun das auch.
Und zahlen dabei so Ablösesummen, wie man sie so aus dem Profifußball kennt.
Also sowas wie, wenn du zu uns gehst, dann kriegst du irgendwie sowas wie 100 Millionen Dollar.
Mhm.
Also beim Fußball werden die, glaube ich, an den Verein gezahlt,
wo man den Spieler wegholt.
Aber… Ja, teilweise, ja, stimmt,
also klar, auch, aber auch die Spieler können davon profitieren,
die Manager und keine Ahnung und so weiter und Gehalt ist ja da sozusagen auch
noch mit drin, aber es ist ein hohes Gehalt, Ablösesumme war jetzt vielleicht
nicht der richtige Begriff, aber hohe Gehaltszahlung,
sicherlich vielleicht auch in Aktien und so weiter, wie das normalerweise,
Normalerweise läuft, aber wir reden hier wirklich über bemerkenswerte Summen,
die für Beschäftigte, potenziell Beschäftigte gezahlt werden von Meta.
Einfach um alles, was an Talent gerade da ist, weil es ist dünn gesät,
also das wirkliche richtige AI-Talent, weil sie halt einfach der Meinung sind,
man müsste hier mithalten.
Müsst ihr jetzt noch kurz den Hörerinnen und Hörern, also das heißt nicht,
das sind nicht Leute, die gut prompten können, sondern Leute,
die dafür sorgen, dass so eine AI funktioniert.
Genau, die, die also wirklich diese Systeme weiterentwickeln und die da mathematisch,
informatisch einfach auf der Höhe sind und wissen, was sie tun und das Feld
im Blick haben und potenzielle Leader sind in irgendwelchen Developergruppen.
Also jetzt die Regeln, also wir hatten die Regeln, die mit der KI-Verordnung
kommen, ein bisschen geschildert.
Für Hochrisiko-KI gelten die Regeln aber dann erst 2027,
weil die Regeln zwischen 6 Monaten und 36 Monaten brauchen, bis sie wirklich gelten.
Also da gibt es so verschiedenste Teile und manches geht so lang.
Nee, also existierende Anbieter müssen halt bis 26 irgendwie da,
also in einem Jahr gilt dann sozusagen irgendwie die nächste Stufe und Systeme,
die jetzt ab jetzt überhaupt neu auf den Markt kommen, für die gilt es dann erst in zwei Jahren.
Wobei neu dann auch irgendwie noch definiert ist mit wie viel Prozent von einem
alten System da drin ist und so weiter.
Das sind alles so schwammige Versuche also auch so die Definition was ist ein
großes System? Das ist ja da sozusagen auch noch so ein Kriterium.
Großes System ist definiert mit wenn du irgendwie mehr als 10 Jota Flops für
dein Training einsetzt.
Also 10 hoch 25 Flops.
Das ist so die Trainingsleistung, die die von OpenAI für GPT-4 vor zwei Jahren
in Anspruch genommen wurde. Das ist so die Definition.
Wobei man sich halt auch fragt, wo kommt die Zahl her, wie kann man die belegen etc.
Also was diese Verordnung zum Beispiel verlangt, sind eben diese Risikobewertungen,
dass du überhaupt erstmal sagst,
was soll dieses Modell hier eigentlich machen und daraus ergibt sich dann,
ist das überhaupt riskant, was du hier machst?
Dann gibt es Qualitätsanforderungen für die Daten, Diskriminierungsverbot,
klar, wenn in dem Ding irgendwas beibringen darfst und eben auch Dokumentationspflichten darüber,
was das Ding macht, welche Entscheidung es trifft oder so.
Also klingt erstmal schon alles halbwegs sinnvoll, aber es ist aber natürlich
etwas bitter, wenn eine derartige Regulierung eher zum Standortnachteil wird. Also du hast ja.
Also machen wir uns nichts vor, Deutschland ist bei dieser Entwicklung nicht
vorne dabei und Regulierungen,
die diese Technologie einschränken, das hast du ja auch gerade schon so ein
bisschen gesagt, wenn sich jetzt die US-Unternehmen sagen, das ist schön,
was ihr da macht, ist so ein Scheißegal, wenn ihr benutzt so Sachen eben nicht.
Und Deutschland oder Europa nicht wirklich was auf der Hand hat,
dann ist auch diese Regulierung eben machtlos.
Und wenn du nicht hingehst und sagst so, diese Regulierung werden wir aber auch durchsetzen.
Dann gibt es eben in Europa keine KI.
Und dieser Stand-off, den traut sich Europa ja nicht so wirklich.
Und entsprechend, wenn du eine halbherzige Regulierung machst und tolerierst,
dass andere sich eben nicht dran halten,
dann schneidest du einfach nur in dein eigenes Fleisch, weil dann werden andere
einfach ohne diesen regulatory overhead ihren Tanz machen und ihre AIs machen und fertig ist.
Und danach sieht das für mich gerade so ein bisschen aus ich denke durchaus
sinnvolle Ideen drin aber wenn du dann sagst, der Staat muss sich jetzt erstmal
sowieso nicht dran halten der muss ja nur die Demokratie verteidigen der muss ja jetzt nicht,
auf einmal aufpassen dass er
nicht dabei diskutiert oder so das wäre jetzt ein bisschen aufwendig und,
da bin ich nicht so sicher Tja, wie schön das jetzt ist. Werden wir mal sehen.
Erstmal wird jetzt halt noch niemanden so wirklich treffen, ne?
Und dann gibt es diesen, was ist mit diesem Code of Practice?
Das ist dieses im letzten Jahr ausgearbeitete Sonderfreiwilliges Ding für die
großen Anbieter, wo die sich quasi selbst bewerten können und das wird ihnen
dann halt positiv angerichtet.
Wo aber eben, wie gesagt, Meta gesagt hat, das machen wir nicht,
wir beschreiben uns hier nicht und könnt ihr sehen, wo ihr bleibt.
Und dann, was hat Europa dann gemacht?
Keine Ahnung. Also ich meine, das steht natürlich jetzt noch aus,
wie das Enforcement hier sein soll.
Also vielleicht läuft das ja so wie beim Digital Markets Act,
dass so die EU zur Hochform aufläuft und sich da Meta rauszieht und einprügelt
und sagt, jetzt müsst ihr aber euer Facebook mal wirklich ausschalten.
Aber ich glaube Meta setzt auch so ein bisschen darauf dass sie mit Trump im
Rücken derzeit einfach aus Europa alles raus,
pressen können, wie wir das ja jetzt schon gesehen haben mit Großbritannien
dass sich die USA querstellen, so nach dem Motto, wenn ihr was gegen unsere,
Digitalindustrie tut, dann,
kriegt ihr es mit mir zu tun und was weiß ich, Zölle hier, keine Ahnung andere
Sachen und ich meine da haben sie uns halt einfach auch bei den Eiern, weil,
Europa hat halt eigentlich nichts im Angebot.
Also wir sind ohne die amerikanischen Tools, sind wir halt verloren.
Da kommen wir als nächstes zu. Vorher muss ich noch in diesem gesamten Kontext,
was du gerade schon gesagt hast, dass hier so unglaubliche Gehälter gezahlt werden für die AI,
Spezialisten und Spezialistinnen, von denen es eben sehr wenige gibt. Und,
Wir haben hier von dem Kartellverfahren gegen Google schon öfter berichtet,
in dessen Kontext es passieren könnte, dass Google gezwungen wird,
den Webbrowser Chrome zu verkaufen,
der eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hat die von Google die geeignet ist,
Google dabei zu helfen seine eigene marktbeherrschende Stellung weiter zu zementieren,
und jetzt ist die Frage, wer würde denn zum Beispiel, wer würde denn Google
Chrome kaufen, also warum würde man das kaufen?
Ein Produkt, was kein Geld verdient.
Verdient kein Geld.
Aber eine Menge Geld kostet.
Genau, kostet Geld. Wobei, naja, ein bisschen Geld kriegen sie ja dafür,
wenn dann jemand... Ah ne, Quatsch, ne.
Nein, nein, das kostet eine ganze Menge Geld.
Es spart ihnen das Geld, was sie sonst anderen Browser-Herstellern bezahlen
müssten, damit ihre Google-Searchbar standardmäßig da drin ist.
Diese Diskussion hatten wir, wir haben es ja sehr ausführlich besprochen,
aber natürlich ist die Idee, warum Google diesen Browser hat,
dass sie damit sicherstellen, dass es schön bei Google gesucht wird.
Und entsprechend fragst du dich, wer würde denn Google Chrome kaufen,
stellt sich raus, Perplexity und OpenAI haben natürlich großes Interesse, dieses Ding zu kaufen.
Perplexity hat 34,5 Milliarden US-Dollar dafür angeboten, hat gesagt,
die Kohle haben wir von Investoren gesichert.
Dieser Preis übertrifft bei Weitem den Wert von Perplexity.
Aber es ist natürlich auch selbstverständlich, dass der Wert unmittelbar,
sobald Perplexity oder wenn es OpenAI, OpenAI hat auch eine Kaufabsicht bekundet,
egal welches AI-Unternehmen den Browser kauft,
ja, also das ist ja, auf den meisten Computern ist Google Chrome der Internetknopf, ne?
Und wenn du jetzt sagst, wir sind hier OpenAI mit ChatGPT oder wir sind Perplexity
und wir können uns für einen niedrigen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag den Internetknopf kaufen.
Das würde ich schon machen an deren Stelle. Und dass die natürlich den Browser
letztendlich, also ich meine, die Technologie, die sie bauen,
auch das hatten wir ja hier in den Kommentaren und in den Sendungen schon regelmäßig
besprochen, die Technologie, die sie da bauen, ist de facto das Ende des Browsers und des Netzes.
Wenn das so weitergeht, ist das nicht mehr Webseite, Quatsch,
Wikipedia-Seite oder so, das wird es einfach nicht mehr geben du kannst eine
API bauen und wenn du Glück hast,
schickt dir jemand eine KI vorbei und fragt danach also es ist ja jetzt schon
übrigens ein Problem dass die ganzen lernenden KIs auf den Webseiten rumhämmern
und einen großen Teil des Traffics ausmachen das soll ja nicht so bleiben,
oder sagen wir mal, das soll ja auf jeden Fall effizienter gemacht werden und
deren Ziel ist natürlich, wenn Perplexity sagt, wir wollen Chrome sein,
dann ist das Ziel, dass du das Ding aufmachst und dann ist da Perplexity und
dann bleibst du auch da, bitteschön.
Und auch dieser ganze Werbemarkt, wie wir ihn jetzt kennen.
Die schicken sich auf jeden Fall an, das neue Interface zu sein und die neue Integration.
Und in solchen Geboten kann man dann natürlich, gibt es einen kleinen Blitz
von, wie die Zukunft dann wohl so aussehen soll nach deren Vorstellungen und
ich glaube, das ist nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass sie auch so aussehen wird.
Also, das ist wirklich ein haariges Thema,
weil ich kann mir diese Auskoppelung von Chrome aus Google ehrlich gesagt so
richtig nicht vorstellen, weil die Leute,
also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das bei Google so organisiert ist,
aber es gibt ja, ich bin mir relativ sicher,
Ja, was heißt, ich bin mir relativ sicher.
Ich kann mir so richtig nicht vorstellen, dass es so eine Chrome-Company gibt,
wo jetzt nur die Leute angestellt sind, die an Chrome arbeiten.
Also die werden schon irgendwo ein Team haben, was das macht.
Das ist ja nicht irgendwie so, dass jeder morgens bei Google zur Arbeit kommt
und sagt, ach, heute mach ich mal ein bisschen was an Chrome.
Und morgen mach ich wieder AI dann. Aber heute mach ich hier bei Chrome und Fenster anders.
Ja gut, die sind dem Team zugeordnet, aber nicht unbedingt so einem Commercial Entity.
Also wer sagt, dass die Leute, die jetzt an Chrome arbeiten,
auch mitverkauft werden, wenn sozusagen das Produkt Chrome verkauft wird?
Also okay, du meinst, was überhaupt die Entity ist.
Was wird da verkauft? Und wenn man es kauft, welcherlei Personal bekommt man?
Weil Chrome ist ja im Prinzip eine der beiden großen Web-Implementierungen,
Web-Browser-Implementierungen.
Es gibt WebKit.
Die kriegst du gar nicht weiterentwickeln. Das ist ein Grund mehr.
Du kaufst im Prinzip nur die Rechte, die Nachfolgesoftware bereitzustellen.
Dass du sagst, alles klar, wir haben das Ding jetzt gekauft.
Ab jetzt holt er sich seine Updates von unserem Server hier.
Der Quellcode ist eh offen und dann sagst du, und dann sagt Google,
wolltest du hier unser DOM-Parser-Entwicklerteam haben und dann sagt Black City, eigentlich nicht.
Was machen die? Ach, DOM-Trees rendern, HTML und so, ne?
Ja, schon noch ein bisschen komplizierter.
Ne, dann sagen die, das brauchen wir nicht, das möchten wir eigentlich nicht mehr haben.
Wir wollen nur den Search Bar kaufen.
Ja, genau, wir wollen eigentlich nur den Internet-Klopf kaufen.
Ja, ich meine, was würde Google dann tun?
Die würden natürlich, also angenommen, es käme jetzt wirklich dazu.
Ich habe echt meine Zweifel, dass es dazu kommen wird.
Ich kann ja nicht genau sagen, warum, aber mein Bauchgefühl sagt irgendwie,
sie werden Google nicht dazu zwingen. Weil das ist ja...
Dann wird Google auch nicht verkaufen, weil dann haut Google natürlich seine AI da rein.
Ja klar, aber angenommen, sie würden jetzt dazu gezwungen werden und Perplexity
würde tatsächlich etwas kaufen, was wo Chrom dran steht und sie würden vielleicht
auch ein paar Entwickler noch mit dazu bekommen, die ja dann auch erstmal dafür arbeiten.
Wäre denn die dann in so einer Kette rausgeführt oder wie kriegst du die dazu?
Ja eben, also das bezweifle ich halt auch schon mal, dass man die Entwickler
so ohne weiteres bekommt, aber selbst wenn es so wäre, sagen wir mal Perplexity,
würde es gelingen mit dem Geld, was sie dann diesen Entwicklern bieten,
so einen halbwegs sustainable Pfad hinzubekommen mit, jetzt können wir dieses
Produkt auch für die nächsten zwei Jahre auf dem Markt behalten und weiter aktualisieren.
Angenommen, dieses Schicksal würde Google treffen, dann würden die doch wirklich
einen Tag später einen neuen Browser aufmachen, der auf ihrer Homepage zum Runterladen ist.
Der heißt dann aber nicht mehr Chrome, sondern der heißt dann, weiß ich nicht.
Also das halte ich für nicht ganz so wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ihnen verboten wird, wieder einen anzubieten.
Man kann ja jetzt kein Betätigungsverbot aussprechen.
Dann würde man, also auf jeden Fall hätten sie dann schon das Problem,
also ich glaube, ich glaube, da machst du dir ein bisschen zu einfach.
Da würden schon natürlich irgendwelche Dinge greifen, insbesondere wenn du Firmenteile
oder Produkte verkaufst, ist es jetzt nicht so schwer, dass der Kunde natürlich
sagt, wenn ich dir 34 Milliarden gebe, um dir diesen Browser abzukaufen,
dann möchte ich nicht, dass du morgen einen neuen machst.
Erst recht nicht mit der Open-Source-Code-Basis, für die ich gerade die Maintenanship gekauft habe.
Trotzdem ist das auch im Weiteren eigentlich eine Diskussion,
die ich gar nicht führen möchte.
Das Spannende ist, dass die den Internet-Club haben wollen, nicht irgendwelche,
mir ist kackegal, wirklich Tim, ernsthaft, richtig, völlig scheißegal,
wie das Entwicklerteam dann da ist oder so.
Und das ist auch Perplexity völlig egal, weil es denen darum geht,
dass das der Internetknopf ist.
Das habe ich schon verstanden.
Und ob jetzt Google dann einen Entwickler an der Kette rausführt und sagt,
der war das, den müsst ihr nehmen oder so.
Das ist völlig, oder ob Google einfach sagt, wisst ihr was, der findet sich
morgen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt wieder, weil wir befeuern den jetzt einfach,
weil wir keinen Browser mehr entwickeln.
Also diese Technicalities sind mir relativ egal, weil es darum geht bei diesem Handel nicht.
Es geht bei diesem Handel darum, dass jemand gerne den,
also ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand Google Chrome kauft mit dem 10-Jahres-Ziel
immer noch der beste HTML-Renderer zu sein.
Sondern dass sie also oder wahrscheinlich schon damit diese Funktionalität noch
da ist weil das brauchen die Leute ja um auf ihre Google Docs oder ihre Sharepoints
oder ihre YouTube Videos zuzugreifen,
aber die eigentliche Idee ist, dass das Ding immer weniger HTML anzeigt.
Immer weniger HTML.
Also immer weniger Webseiten von anderen Leuten Also HTML klar.
Natürlich schon Ja, also Also das ist die Idee von AI.
Ja, ist schon klar. Ich meine, das macht ja auch Google mittlerweile.
So ist es ja nicht. Also du hast ja auch auf Google diese AI-Zusammenfassung.
Deswegen wollen sie ja auch den Grund abkaufen.
Ich finde das insofern bemerkenswert und frage mich halt gerade,
ich denke über die Legitimität dieses Moves nach.
Nicht jetzt aus der Perspektive von Perplexity, sondern aus der rechtlichen Legitimität.
Weil die Drohung ist ja, wir nehmen euch das Chrom weg, weil ihr wart ja woanders böse.
Es ging ja nie um Chrom. Sondern Chrom ist ja quasi nur so ein Bestrafungsvorschlag
für eure Suchmaschine falsch ausgerichtet.
Möchtest du jetzt hier über die Legitimität von Entscheidungen von US-Gerichten
oder noch schlimmer irgendwelchen Antitrust-Behörden, die letztendlich der Regierung gehören?
Und die Legitimität der Entscheidungen von der Trump-Regierung.
Jetzt werden wir aber völlig.
Ja gut, die Nummer ist jetzt ja nicht neu unter Trump, sondern das war ja schon länger anhängig.
Das ist jetzt eigentlich nichts, was sie groß, also vielleicht kommen sie noch
auf die Idee, das zu beeinflussen.
Damit würde ich im Übrigen rechnen, dass sie das jetzt das Feuer austreten,
weil sie da Google beschützen wollen.
Vielleicht haben sie auch zu viele Freunde bei OpenAI und wollen Google eine auswischen.
Das weiß ich nicht, je nachdem, wer jetzt mehr Geld gegeben hat für Trumps Party
zur Eröffnung wahrscheinlich.
Also ja, das ist.
Also das Verfahren ist 2023 vom Justizministerium eingeleitet worden.
Also ich wollte gar nicht so lange darüber reden.
Auf jeden Fall greifen die KI-Herstellenden, also auch OpenAI hat natürlich
ein großes Problem, tatsächlich im Vergleich zu Apple und Google,
dass sie halt von mir aus eine wunderschöne AI haben,
die aber noch nicht den Zugang zu allen Geräten, also es macht halt schon einen Unterschied,
ob du eine App bist oder ob du das Phone lieferst, also ChatGPT oder Apple Intelligence,
die Betriebssystemintegration, wenn sie dann irgendwann mal kommt,
bisher habe ich da immer nur Gerede von gehört, also bisher habe ich hier noch
keine Apple Intelligence irgendwie großartig wahrgenommen, so wie ich das gerne
hätte, zumindest nicht.
Das ist auch derzeit mehr Apple-Stupidity als Intelligence Genau.
Aber wenn das dann irgendwann einmal da drin wäre und klar Apple holt sich das
von OMAI oder so aber natürlich ist, wenn du in einem sehr weit verbreiteten,
drin bist und das wäre eben beispielsweise ein Android-Mobil-Telefon oder ein iPhone.
Das sind so die beiden Dinge, die sich sehr gut eignen, um die AI-Integration
da drin zu haben und ein potenziell auch minderwertiges Produkt einfach automatisch
zum Marktführer zu machen.
Und wenn du jetzt OpenAI bist und sagst, wäre dir schlecht, wenn wir auch sowas
hätten, dann kommt dir natürlich die Idee, Chrome oder etwas ähnliches zu kaufen.
So, aber wir reden ja jetzt in Deutschland über die digitale Souveränität.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, das ist so ein Fremdwort für Deutsche.
Es wird immer nur über die Souveränität geredet, wenn wieder irgendwas passiert
ist. So wie letztes Wochenende.
Was ist denn passiert, Tim?
Ist mir bei dir nicht ganz viel Geld abgebucht worden?
Habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Bei PayPal? Guck mal, ob noch Kohle da ist.
Ja, es gab wohl einen Ausfall eines Systems zur Erkennung betrügerischer Aktivitäten bei PayPal.
Deren Aufgabe ist festzustellen, wenn irgendwelche Betrüger versuchen,
unrechtmäßig Geld von fremden Konten abzubuchen.
Und ja, das ist wohl irgendwie, hatte Fehler oder ist komplett ausgefallen,
ein bisschen unklar, was dazu geführt hat, dass sämtliche Lastschriften, die aufliefen,
ungeprüft durchgeführt wurden.
Also ein Schutzsystem, was normalerweise diese ganzen Lastschriften,
die dort auflaufen, prüft, hat es dann nicht mehr so geprüft.
Und das ist wohl auch den Sicherheitssystemen deutscher Banken aufgefallen.
Ich weiß jetzt in diesem Bericht ist nur von deutschen Banken die Rede,
mögen auch noch andere Banken gewesen sein, aber deutsche Banken waren definitiv
Teil des Spiels, aber ich glaube Lastschrift ist im Wesentlichen auch ein deutsches
Ding, von daher mag es sich auch nur auf den deutschen Markt im Wesentlichen beziehen.
Also du hast in Europa nicht überall dieses Prinzip von das Schrift.
So ein typisch deutsches Bankenprodukt. Wir haben zwar mittlerweile so einen
EU-harmonisierten Bankenmarkt, aber das heißt nicht automatisch,
dass du all die Produkte,
die wir jetzt aus Deutschland gewohnt sind, genauso auch in anderen Ländern findest.
Naja, auf jeden Fall scheint es den Sicherheitssystemen deutscher Banken aufgefallen
zu sein, dass PayPal einfach alles ungeprüft durchführt.
Also offensichtlich haben sie nicht mehr so viele Rejections bekommen oder so, keine Ahnung.
Naja, was wohl dann eben auch dazu geführt hat, dass Benutzer sich über illegale
Abbuchungen beklagt haben oder eben dann,
weil die deutschen Banken ihre Lastschriften dann nämlich komplett zu PayPal
blockiert haben, dass eben Überweisungen, mit denen sie gerechnet haben,
dann nicht gekommen sind.
Möglicher Umfang dieser blockierten Zahlungen geschätzt 10 Milliarden Euro.
Was? An einem Wochenende setzt Paypal 10 Milliarden Euro.
Seitdem sie das blockiert haben.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann es wieder lief, aber das ist so die Größenordnung.
Scheint einiges unterwegs zu sein. Allein die Bayerische Landesbank 4 Milliarden Euro.
Genau, naja. Irgendwie ist das aber auch so richtig keine News,
weil ich meine, kann ja mal passieren, dass mal was ausfällt.
Ja, passiert halt mal. 10 Milliarden hier, 10 Milliarden da,
meine Güte. Der stellt sich auch immer an, ja.
Das ist so diese deutsche Anstellerei.
Mann ey.
Meine 10 Milliarden auf einmal weg.
Ja, aber der Politik ist aber aufgefallen, das ist ja gar kein europäisches System, dieses PayPal.
Das kann auch kaputt gehen. Warum haben wir denn da nichts Schönes?
Ach so. Moment, das ist doch gar kein deutsches System. Das kann auch kaputt gehen.
Genau. Naja, es wollen auf jeden Fall alle wieder eine europäische Alternative haben zu PayPal.
Weil, kann ja nicht sein, dass das mal was nicht funktioniert.
Während es allerdings problemlos funktioniert hat keiner gesagt.
Da wollte keiner eine Alternative haben.
Wann wurde Paypal gegründet? Vor 20 Jahren oder was?
1998.
Von 27 Jahren. Nach 27 Jahren sagt die, Moment.
Letzte Woche hat das nicht funktioniert. Wir brauchen eine Alternative.
Die gibt es ja auch schon.
Gibt es?
Kennst du nicht? Heißt Vero.
Nee, kann ich nicht.
Das ist sowieso ein geiles Wort. Angeblich ist es aus Wii und Euro zusammengesetzt.
Das sieht so ein Scheiß aus.
Komisch, hat sich nicht durchgesetzt.
Die Domain war noch frei. Naja, ich meine, das wird sich natürlich auch nicht
durchsetzen, weil es halt einfach kaum was kann.
Das ist übrigens der Nachfolger eines anderen Rohrkrepierers namens Giropay,
was ja auch schon mal so ein Versuch war.
Das ist immer der Versuch der deutschen Banken, auf Basis ihrer existierenden
Infrastruktur, in irgendeiner Form,
was ranzuflanschen, was dann irgendwie mit dem Internet funktioniert.
Ja, das kann halt mit so einem System, was aus dem Internet kommt,
nicht wirklich mithalten.
Und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie dieses Vero sich irgendwie nennt.
Im Wesentlichen nehmen da nur irgendwelche Sparkassen dran teil und das ist
jetzt nicht so, dass das so einfach da ist.
Was man halt wieder bräuchte, So eine ähnliche Diskussion, ein bisschen wie digitaler Euro,
wäre ja eigentlich eher eine europäische Überweisungsanbindung an E-Mail,
Web, Internet,
die standardisiert ist für alle und an der auch automatisch alle teilnehmen.
Ich denke, das ist die einzige Möglichkeit.
Jetzt fängst du schon wieder an, hier irgendwie sinnvolle Details von einer
völlig 27 Jahre hat keiner.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich bin halt für die Zukunft zuständig und muss ja auch darüber reden.
Da musst du es doch tun. Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es alles ein bisschen lächerlich und Vero.
PayPal läuft jetzt schon wieder ab. Ja, Vero.
Kannst du gleich mal an den Account klicken. Kannst du mal gucken,
ob dir jemand Geld schickt.
Also Paypal hat natürlich schon wirklich einen,
Nutzungskomfort, der wirklich sehr hoch und angenehm ist.
Ist natürlich bitter, wenn bei denen das Fraud Prevention System schief geht
und dann die deutschen Banken einspringen müssen.
Also das finde ich eigentlich das Faszinierendere, dass den Banken das schneller auffällt als PayPal.
Das ist doch eigentlich hier die Meldung, oder?
Ich wollte ja gerade noch sagen,
Vero, da war die Domain noch frei, aber die ist ja noch nicht mal frei gewesen.
Das heißt dann vero-wallet.eu.
Das hat zu mir das Vero-Wolleten eben das Geld.
Naja.
Interessant finde ich, aber ja, gut. Dann gab es jetzt eine, und ich finde...
Das habe ich ja bei dir jetzt auch rausgehört, ja, Paypal ist im Fraud-Prevention-System ausgefallen.
Super ärgerlich, ja. Also ist es natürlich auch für die Banken,
das ist ein, die Leute, denen jetzt das Geld fehlt oder das,
wo das Geld nicht durchgekommen ist, die geben ja nicht Paypal die Schuld, sondern der Bank.
Weil das Geld fehlt ja von der Bank und nicht vom Paypal.
So, das heißt, und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund, warum diese Diskussion
da jetzt so geführt wird, Dass die deutschen Banken jetzt die unzufriedenen Kundinnen haben,
während PayPal schuld ist.
Das kann ich mir als einzigen halbwegs sinnvollen Grund dafür vorstellen,
dass man überhaupt eine digitale Souveränitätsdebatte daraus entstehen lässt.
Weil außer dass Paypal Amerikanern gehört, ist da ja jetzt nichts anders dran,
aber dieser Fehler ist ja jetzt auch nicht passiert, weil sie Amerikaner sind.
Insofern ist diese Debatte so ein bisschen komisch, allerdings hat sich dann,
und das war dann das nächste große Thema,
in diesem Kontext auch mal die Claudia Plattner von der vom BSI geäußert zum
Thema digitale Souveränität.
Und dann sagt sie, nun, es gibt zwar hier Fortschritte,
aber es ist doch klar, dass manche der großen Firmen, vor allem aus den USA,
jetzt schon zehn Jahre Vorsprung haben, was entsprechende Investitionen angeht.
Und somit machte die Meldung die Runde, dass Claudia Plattner sagt,
digitale Souveränität ist für Deutschland vorerst einfach mal nicht erreichbar.
Hate to break it to you. Und sagt dann, naja, man braucht eine Strategie,
was man von außen kauft und wie man darüber eine gewisse Kontrolle gewinnt.
Beispielsweise, indem das BSI mit Google kooperiert, nennt sie jetzt als Beispiel,
und Datensouveränität irgendwie in den Cloud-Lösungen nochmal versucht wird, herzustellen.
Ja, und dass es jetzt letztendlich natürlich Deutschland sich Gedanken machen
muss, möglichst schnell irgendwo noch bei KI irgendwie was hinzukriegen und Sicherheit.
Aber dass jetzt so die Idee in nächster Zeit hier mal einen auf souveräne,
also digitale Souveränität zu erreichen, absurd ist.
Und jetzt finde ich das, also auf eine Weise glaube ich, sie hat jetzt einfach
mal nur die Wahrheit gesagt.
Sie hat jetzt einfach nur mal gesagt, Leute, lass uns mal ehrlich machen.
Das werden wir jetzt so nicht.
Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß.
Ohne Scheiß. Komm, ehrlich jetzt. Hey, pass auf. Ja, ja, genau.
Aber jetzt mal im Ernst. Und,
gleichzeitig,
sie sagt, es ist unrealistisch zu glauben, dass wir es kurzfristig alles selbst
können. Das muss man schon auch sagen.
Sie hat also nicht gesagt, langfristig kannst du das... Also sie hat noch nicht
gesagt langfristig. Sie hat erstmal nur kurzfristig.
Aber bei Deutschland und digital bedeutet kurzfristig ja langfristig.
Ich würde mal mittelfristig sagen. Mindestens mittelfristig.
Also kurzfristig heißt in Deutschland mindestens mittelfristig.
Mittelfristig. Das ist auch, glaube ich, wenn in dem Kurort wieder ein Mobilfunkmaß
steht. Mittelfristig gibt es da auch wieder ein Netz.
Jetzt hat sich aber, dafür gibt es natürlich dann auch wieder Kritik,
weil Und auch diese Kritik kann ich wiederum zumindest nachvollziehen,
wenn man sagt, Moment mal, wenn jetzt hier die obersten Digitalleute in Deutschland
noch nicht mal mehr dran glauben,
dann muss man und damit letztendlich eine Weichenstellung machen,
die nicht dorthin geht, die quasi nicht dorthin führt.
Dann kann es ja auch eine selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung werden.
Okay, ich meine, aber sie ist nicht die Digitalministerin, sie ist die Chefin des BSI.
Ja, sie ist die, aber ich habe ja gesagt, die obersten Digitalleute in Deutschland.
Ich dachte, wir sind das.
Ja, aber formal.
So, verstehe ich.
Und auf jeden Fall, naja,
natürlich würde man sich freuen, wenn in diesem Land in einem solchen Jahr andere
Diskussionen geführt werden würden, als eben darüber,
dass man den digitalen Souveränitätsgedanken eventuell noch nicht mal mehr verfolgen sollte.
Es gab dann so ein bisschen,
also der GovTech Intelligence Hub sagt zum Beispiel,
man muss ja gar nicht unbedingt auf Autarkie hinarbeiten, sondern halten es
klüger, statt vollständiger Unabhängigkeit auf eine gegenseitige Abhängigkeit zu steuern.
Klingt erstmal tatsächlich vielleicht sinnvoller, gegenseitige Abhängigkeiten
stabilisieren, vielleicht Handelsbeziehungen, hast du einen gegenseitigen Hebel,
allerdings wüsste ich jetzt nicht, von welcher Technologie wir kurz- oder mittelfristig
die USA abhängig machen könnten, im Digitalen.
Aber Schleswig-Holstein will zum Beispiel ohne Word Teams und so weiter auskommen mit Nextcloud.
Schleswig-Holstein verabschiedet sich von Microsoft. Also es wäre ja nicht schlecht, wenn sie das schaffen.
Die Effizienz einer Verwaltung oder Behörde die kriegst du ja auch ohne Microsoft in den Keller also.
Ja
also ich bin gespannt sie sind nicht die ersten, die versuchen sich aus der
Microsoft Umklammerung zu lösen, aber oft wird das ja dadurch torpediert,
dass die anderen das alle nicht machen wollen und dann gibt es einfach zu viel,
Kompatibilitätsprobleme Das ist auch die Frage, inwiefern Open Source da mithalten kann.
Und dann gibt es natürlich eine Meldung der Open Source Business Alliance,
die sagt, offener Brief an Claudia
Plattner, digitale Souvenität für Deutschland und Europa ist möglich.
Sprechen dem,
widersprechen nehmen. Oder,
weisen natürlich darauf hin, dass es diese Möglichkeiten dann doch gibt.
Naja. Mal schauen, wie das wird mit der digitalen Souveränität.
Das wird bestimmt nicht mehr lange dauern.
Vor allem, weil wir ja ein Sicherheitspaket bekommen.
Genau, da ist das BSI ja eigentlich richtiger Ansprechpartner.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also eher noch als im anderen Thema.
Ach, du meinst den Cyberdome? Wir haben den Cyberdome gar nicht erwähnt.
Cyberdome.
Ja, BSI zuständig, Sicherheit. Dubrind möchte gerne, also Dubrind ist ja auch
wirklich Quelle der Freude.
Also was der jetzt möchte ist, der will einen Cyberdome.
Und diesen Begriff hat er schon geprägt, als er Ende Juni in Israel war und
dann hat weil die ja den, wie heißt es, Iron Dome und dann hat er gesagt,
hier, genau hat er sich das Raketensystem angeschaut,
und hat sich, hat hier Wargames oder,
Telekom hat ja auch so ein Hackertacho, wo die ganze Zeit so die bösen Datenpakete
hin und her fliegen Kennst du, ne?
Cybersicherheitstacho oder sowas heißt das. Kennst du das? Das ist wirklich
genau das. Es ist genau so.
Da fliegen dann so diese Datenpakete über so einen Globus.
Da kannst du dir den Cyberwar angucken. Telekom, warte, den müssen wir verlinken.
Sicherheitstacho oder sowas. Sicherheitstacho.
Hier, zack, da ist er. Bumm, siehst du? Boah, ist schon wieder...
Der hat hier ein Alka-Paket geflogen. Siehst du das?
Ja, wow. Das ist ja wie bei Wargames.
Das ist so peinlich. So, und das, da, also hier ist ja klar,
du siehst ja hier, wie die Pakete fliegen.
So, und wenn du da jetzt ein Cyber-Dom...
Du musst das jetzt schon ein bisschen plastischer ausführen,
weil ich sehe das ja aber, unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Die haben doch alle Wargames geguckt. Also man sieht hier eine Weltkarte und
auf dieser Weltkarte fliegen wie Raketen die IP-Pakete, die bösen Pakete.
Und da steht dann hier zum Beispiel, das gerade wieder von den USA ist gerade das 702.919.795.
Paket in den letzten 30 Tagen geflogen. So viele Milliarden Hacker-Pakete schicken die USA.
Und wenn man sich das jetzt so anschaut, wie diese Raketenpakete,
die Cyber-Raketen hier fliegen,
kommt einem natürlich der Gedanke, da brauchst du einen Cyber-Dome,
damit da nicht mehr so viele Hacker-Pakete kommen.
Hacker-Pakete.
Hackback-Rakete war doch auch schon mal, glaube ich, Sendungstitel bei uns.
Eckbeck-Rakete?
Eckbeck-Rakete, ja klar, weil,
du siehst doch den Cyber-War hier, Tim, guck dir das mal an.
Siehst du auch?
Schockierend.
Das ist real.
Das ist schockierend, der Cyber-War. So, und da hat der Dobrindt gesagt,
wir brauchen jetzt einen Cyber-Dome. Und was meint er damit?
Tja,
er möchte gerne in fünf Bereichen mit Israel kooperieren.
Das hat er da schon im Juni gesagt. Und jetzt sagt er, er möchte gerne ein schlagkräftiges
digitales Schutzschild gegen
Spionage, Sabotage und für den Schutz der kritischen Infrastruktur haben.
Und jetzt sagt er, in der Pressemitteilung sagt das BMI, sie möchten eine teilautomatisierte
Abwehr im Netz, den Cyberdome,
Zur Abwehr und Vermeidung von Schäden durch Cyberangriffe.
Bestehende und geplante neue Ansätze zur Detektion, Analyse und Reaktion sollen
zusammengeführt werden.
Und Sie möchten jetzt ein Realisierungskonzept haben. Wenn man jetzt mal daraus
liest, was Sie damit meinen.
Dann heißt es übersetzt,
sie möchten erweiterte Cyberabwehrbefugnisse haben für die Sicherheitsbehörden
des Bundes und mit diesen neuen Befugnissen sollen die Behörden dann schwerwiegende
Angriffe aktiv verhindern,
abmildern oder gar stoppen können.
Also das ist wieder diese, und ich glaube, die Sendung hatte auch den Titel
Hackback-Rakete, weil wir daran genau diese dann doch leicht absurde Idee,
dass da Raketen fliegen, die man abfangen kann.
Mal vielleicht ein bisschen zu verballhornen.
Sowas würden wir noch niemals tun.
Also verhindern, würde ich denken, damit meinen sie eventuell sperren.
Also dass man jetzt quasi sagt,
bekannte IP-Adressen, die mit bösartigem Verhalten in Verbindung stehen,
die möchten wir gerne sperren.
Wir möchten von dieser IP keine eingehenden SMTP-Verbindungen nach Deutschland
haben oder wir möchten, was weiß ich,
die Verbindung von diesem Botnet in Richtung dieses Command-and-Control-Servers,
die möchten wir unterbinden, damit die Ransomware nicht nach Hause telefonieren
kann oder was. was auch immer.
Stoppen. Also abmildern ist eben witzig.
Worin besteht jetzt die Abmilderung? Wurdest du nicht ganz so hart gecybert?
Ihr könnt uns cybern, aber sanft. Soft.
Blümchencybern.
Oh Mann.
Und stoppen, das ist, da verbirgt sich natürlich die Idee drin.
Irgendwie eine Abwehrrakete hinzuschicken.
Eine Abwehrrakete, eine Hackpack.
Eine Hackpack-Rakete.
Da kommt eine Hack und dann kommt eine Hackpack und dann ist,
dann glitzert es am Sternenhimmel, weil die Hackpack-Rakete,
die Hack-Rakete kaputt gemacht hat und alle freuen sich, weil jetzt der Cyberangriff gestoppt wurde.
Naja.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sich in dem Gesetzesentwurf,
den die dann vorlegen werden, die Befugnisse zum Eindringen in IT-Systeme reguliert werden.
Und dass die sagen, dass sie quasi auf breiterer Schulter mit niedrigerer Schwelle, dass,
die Kompetenz haben wollen in deutsche und nicht deutsche Systeme potenziell einzudringen.
Weil wie du wirklich einen Angriff stoppen könntest, ist natürlich indem du ihn verunmöglichst.
Also sagst du hier, blockieren den, wir blockieren den, wir blockieren die IP-Adresse,
dann kommen die morgen von der nächsten IP-Adresse, bis du den gesamten V4-Raum
gesperrt hast und dann kannst du im V6-Raum anfangen.
Also das dauert dann ein bisschen länger.
Ein paar tausend Jahre.
Die,
was sie meinen mit,
nachhaltig irgendwie verhindern oder so, das wäre natürlich die Infrastruktur
der Angreifer infiltrieren.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären. Oder teilautomatisierte Reaktion.
Also das,
Wie groß ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es einfach nur Gelaber ist?
Die ist sehr hoch, aber der Mann ist Minister. Wenn der labert,
passiert was. Das ist das Problem.
Das ist ja das Problem, wenn du diese Wurstfresser da in die Regierung holt,
um mal bei Habeck zu bleiben.
Robert Habeck hatte in der Taz ein Interview gegeben, wo er jetzt endlich mal
nicht mehr freundlich war und einfach mal so an einer Stelle oder zwei eben
so rausgerutscht ist, was er wirklich denkt.
Und das ist sehr auch sehr traurig natürlich, dass jemand, der mit ernsthaftem,
Veränderungswillen und einem Verantwortungsbewusstsein in der Regierung war
und sich für, denke ich, ein paar ganz gute Dinge eingesetzt hat.
Jetzt halt von den von so Leuten wie Söder und Julia Klöckner und so dann jetzt
leider natürlich dann doch sehr stark irritiert ist.
Und damit leben muss, dass die den Wahlerfolg hatten und er nicht.
Das glaube ich würde ich auch nicht auch nur schwer ertragen,
dann würde ich mir auch andere Sachen im Leben suchen, was er jetzt eben macht,
darauf der Bezug mit den Würstchen,
naja, also ich denke, der wird irgendwelche Offensivfähigkeiten für die Sicherheitsbehörden
fordern und das Ganze irgendwie mit einem schönen Wort verpacken,
Cyberdome und dann wird er sich
einen Wurststand stellen und sich ein Bier bestellen und wie gesagt, ja,
das Problem das ist nur dummes Gelaber, aber der Mann ist Minister und wenn
der dumm labert, dann passiert was.
Dieses fetischhafte Wurstgefresse von Markus Söder ist ja keine Politik und
es erfüllt dennoch einen Zweck.
Es lenkt ab von den Gründen, die Menschen haben können, sich nicht gesehen und
nicht mitgenommen zu fühlen.
So sagt Habeck in diesem Interview.
Fetischhaftes Wurstgefresse.
Ja und was sagt dann der Söder dazu? Irgendwie so sinngemäß,
die Grünen wollen uns ne Wurst verbieten.
Und schon sitzen die Bayern da und so,
Mann, Mann, Mann. Es ist schon wirklich schade, auf welches Niveau,
Auch in Deutschland die politische Auseinandersetzung dank solcher Vollausfälle wie Markus Söder.
Würde ich in Bayern wohnen, würde ich da wegziehen, weil ich mich so für den Typen schäme.
Da muss ich ja überall wegziehen. Das ist jetzt in Berlin noch nicht sehr viel besser.
Wenigstens kein Wurstfetisch.
Naja, dafür ein Autofetisch. Der ist auch nicht sehr viel schöner.
Naja, aber den haben die in Bayern auch.
Ich sehe es positiv, vielleicht wird der Internet-Tacho ja dann auch mit diesen
Hackback-Raketen dann auch noch, dass sie nicht nur diese kleinen grünen Pfeile
halt im Angriff machen, sondern dass du auch noch gleich sehen kannst,
wie die kleinen grünen Pfeile dann abgeschossen werden von den roten Abwehr-Raketen
und das Ganze schön so in 3D und dann kann man sich so seine Cyber-Brille aufsetzen.
Dann sitze ich mitten im Cyber-Dome.
Ja, der oder du siehst dann an deiner Vision Pro,
wie so die Raketen von hinten auf deinen Computer und im letzten Moment sie
schellen dir an so einem Cyberdom.
Ja. Söder an der Wurstkanone. Und wenn du die Cyberraketen abschießt.
Und woanders sind Leute, die halt...
Noch lachen wir.
Nee, wir lachen. Ja gut, ich werde immer weiter. lachen.
Ich werde lachend sterben. Ich werde lachend sterben, ja.
Meine letzten Worte werden sein Aber dann alles. Okay. So, der,
Wie heißt der? Doverind?
Hat ja jetzt auch hat ein Sicherheitspaket sich jetzt vorgestellt.
Er möchte jetzt die Sicherheit erhöhen, weil wir ja hier so unsicher sind.
Du merkst ja, wie unsicher wir sind in Deutschland.
Total, ich zittere.
Und ich fühle mich auch die ganze Zeit sehr unsicher. Und mit dem Sicherheitspaket
möchte er zwei zentrale Dinge machen.
Achso, es ist das Sicherheitspaket 2.0, sorry. Sicherheitspaket 2.0.
Das wäre wieder so eine alte Version.
Nee, 2.0. Und da geht es ihm um Biometrie und polizeiliche Datenanalyse.
Und er möchte, also wir erinnern uns ja an den Daniela-Klette-Fall,
die RAF-Terroristin, die,
relativ unbehelligt halt hier in Berlin gewohnt hat und irgendwann nach meiner
Überzeugung von diesem Podcast-Team,
mit einem einfachen hier, guck mal, hier kann du mal bitte diese AI gucken,
wer auf Facebook das ist und dann haben sie die auf der Seite von dieser Capoeira-Schule
da gefunden und das war sie dann, ja.
Und dann hat die Polizei gesagt, wir haben die gefunden, wir sind voll cool,
guck mal, was wir gemacht haben mit Internet und so, oder?
Und jetzt möchte der Dobrindt gerne, dass die Polizei das grundsätzlich erstmal darf,
und zwar das gesamte Internet nach Verdächtigen oder auch Zeugen durchsuchen
im Rahmen ihrer Aufgabenerfüllung das bedeutet also keinerlei Grenzen,
also nicht irgendwie so,
darf Terroristen damit suchen oder so oder darf, was weiß ich schwere Schwerverbrecher damit suchen,
sondern im Rahmen ihrer Aufgabenerfüllung heißt so einfach einmal, also egal wann.
Aufgabenerfüllung ist ja fast immer.
Und tja, das ist natürlich ein hat natürlich ein ganz fürchterliches Missbrauchspotenzial,
aber natürlich auch brauchst du dafür halt diese Gesichterdatenbank.
Jetzt haben sie natürlich schon eine von den Passfotos, Das wurde ja schon vor
Jahren quasi breiter verteilt.
Also erst wurden die Passfotos, die biometrischen Passfotos gesammelt,
dann wurden die Datenbanken zusammengeführt, dann wurde der Zugriff darauf ermöglicht.
Und jetzt möchten sie eben das gesamte Internet, Social Media und so weiter
nach Personen durchsuchen können.
Und dafür brauchen sie eben riesige Datenbanken der Menschen,
die im Internet abgebildet sind.
Also du brauchst einmal natürlich die Datenbank, wo du deine Suchmarker drin
hast und dann musst du die ganze Zeit im Internet suchen.
Dann machst du halt riesige Datenbanken und um die irgendwie kleiner zu kriegen,
clusterst du natürlich die Gesichter, die du erkennst.
Weil sonst wird das Internet ja nicht durch... Wenn du jedes Gesicht als ein
neues behandeln würdest, müsstest du ja auch immer durch das gesamte Internet suchen.
Aber wenn du einfach sagst, okay, ich kenne einfach die Gesichter aus dem Internet
und jetzt lasse ich diesen Strom an mir vorbeilaufen, identifiziere die und
wenn ich irgendjemanden nicht identifiziert habe, dann lege ich ein neues Gesicht an,
dann kannst du nur, wenn du einen solchen Index hättest, kannst du ja auch schnell da drin suchen.
Und das bedeutet, sie würden quasi eine Gesichtsdatenbank vom Internet bauen,
die aber eben nach Artikel 5 der KI-Verordnung, haben wir gerade darüber gesprochen,
verboten ist, dass Massenüberwachung und umfassende Profilbildung ist.
Aber das interessiert ja den Dobrindt nicht, der möchte das gerne haben.
Also biometrische Massenüberwachung im Internet mit Profilbildung, das hätte er gerne.
Und dann sagt er, er würde gerne automatisiert persönliche Daten aus bisher
getrennten Datenbanken in eine Super-Datenbank zusammenführen.
Super-Datenbank, Cyber-Dom. Und damit dann eben eine KI-gestützte Auswertung riesiger Datenmengen.
Ja, wovon ist die Rede? natürlich, letztendlich geht es da um Palantir Gotham.
Das möchte er auf Bundesebene haben.
Ist in Deutschland jetzt in drei Bundesländern unter Hessendata,
DAR und VERA schon im Betrieb.
Und Thema digitale Souveränität. Also erstens, das ist das IT-Sicherheitspaket
2, Palantir und biometrische Maßenüberwachung im Internet. Herzlichen Dank.
Da sind wir gegen, falls das noch nicht rausge... Falls man das noch nicht so rausgehört hat.
Was ich aber auch sehr interessant finde, ist, dass ich dann in der Wirtschaftswoche so ein Artikel lese.
Dabei gäbe es Alternativen, auch aus Deutschland. Unternehmen wie OneData bieten
ebenfalls KI-basierte Analysewerkzeuge, die komplexe Datenmengen aus unterschiedlichen
Daten, aus unterschiedlichen Quellen verknüpfen.
Aber ihre Technik wird auf Basis europäischer Datenschutzstandards entwickelt
frage ich mich also das kann ja nichts taugen,
also entweder du machst eine super Datenbank oder nicht aber interessant finde
ich dass der One Data CEO sich bei der Wirtschaftswoche dann im Gespräch beschwert,
weil das der politische Wille fehlt,
die Ausschreibungen die die Polizeibehörden machen sind oft so formuliert dass
sie praktisch auf Palantir hinauslaufen.
Das heißt, du hast, das machst du ja, wenn du was kaufen möchtest und das ist
aber zu teuer und du musst es ausschreiben, dann beschreibst du halt sehr überspezifisch das so.
Also so ungefähr so, wir möchten eine super Datenbank, die mit P anfängt und mit Alantir aufhört.
Was ich aber sehr interessant finde, weil die gleichen Politikerinnen, die dann da,
wenn man einen Tag PayPal 10 Milliarden in die falsche Richtung schiebt,
sagen ja, digitale Souveränität, wir brauchen europäische Alternative oder so,
aber ihre eigene Massenüberwachung.
Ja, das ist aber mittelfristig alles nicht erreichbar.
Ach so, das stimmt. Ah. Ja, stimmt.
Okay. Nee, gut, dann ein paar Landtieren. Ja.
Das ist schon lustig, ne? Also auf der einen Seite Souveränität,
wenn man irgendwie mal wieder auf irgendwas einschlagen kann,
aber wenn man irgendwie eigentlich dann doch lieber Massenüberwachung haben
will, dann sind auch so europäische, deutsche Vorschriften,
grundlegende Annahmen und Verordnungen eigentlich auch irgendwie egal.
Genau. Und dann kommen wir so bei den Abis.
Ja. Super.
Na dann gibt es noch ein bisschen was, ein paar Neuigkeiten im Bereich der Staatstrojaner.
Erstmal wurde im Jahr 2023, also gab es jetzt Statistiken, also vor zwei Jahren
haben sie 130 mal quasi die Erlaubnis bekommen.
Also das geht davon aus, dass es einen Richterinnenvorbehalt dann quasi gab.
Und von den 130 Mal waren sie 68 Mal auch damit erfolgreich.
Wie ist das definiert? Erfolgreich?
Ich würde sagen, dass der Staatsräger auch wirklich zum Einsatz kam,
dass sie eine erfolgreiche Infektion vorgenommen haben.
Kann jetzt natürlich an unterschiedlichen Gründen liegen, warum sie in etwas
unter der Hälfte der Fälle nicht funktioniert hat.
Vielleicht, weil sie, keine Ahnung, also kann ihr tausend Gründe geben,
wissen sie vielleicht nicht.
Also du liest das alles, hat nicht funktioniert, also das Infiltrieren hat nicht
funktioniert oder es kam nichts dabei raus?
Nee, nee, das infiltrieren hat nicht funktioniert.
Also 130 Mal durften sie hacken, 68 Mal haben sie es getan.
Okay.
Und in der Regel Drogen, also primär Drogendelikte,
Betäubungsmittelgesetz und sie haben dabei die kleinen Staatstrojaner eingesetzt.
Und das müsste man nochmal erläutern, weil es auch im weiteren Verlauf eine Rolle spielt.
Es wird unterschieden die Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung, ein System,
das laufende Gespräche und Chats abhören kann und maximal bis zum Zeitpunkt
der Anordnung zurückgehend.
Also angenommen, was weiß ich, am 1.
Januar gibt die Richterin den, sagt, darf die Polizei jetzt,
gibt quasi die erlaubt, ordnet das an.
Und dann brauchen die aber bis zum Februar, bis zum 3.
Februar, bis sie tatsächlich die Infiltration haben. dann dürfen Sie mit der
Quellentelekommunikationsüberwachung alle zukünftigen Kommunikationsinhalte.
Und rückblickend bis zum Zeitpunkt der Anordnung, aber nicht weiter zurück.
Weil das Ding ja diese Fiktion ist, dass sie damit auch eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung
nachahmen und die würde ja auch quasi angeordnet,
dann können sie sofort auf die G10-Schnittstellen und dieser Fiktion folgend
der kleine Staatssträner.
Der große Stadioner, das ist die Online-Durchsuchung, die hackt die Geräte,
um sämtliche Daten auszuleiten.
Das wurde 26 mal angeordnet und in sechs Fällen auch tatsächlich durchgeführt.
Also nur jede vierte trotz Anordnung. Also durchgeführt wieder im Sinne von
hat funktioniert. Hat funktionieren.
Also da, ich würde vermuten, dass es daran liegt, dass,
also gerade jetzt so, wenn die große Online-Durchsuchung angeordnet wird,
dann bist du irgendwo im Bereich auf jeden Fall der sehr schweren Straftatenorganisierten
Kriminalität oder sonstigen.
Und vermutlich werden Menschen, die derartiger Verbrechen verdächtig sind,
schon besondere Sicherheitsvorkehrungen haben.
Also würde ich vermuten, dass sie vielleicht besonders gehärtete Geräte haben
oder besonders vorsichtig sind in ihrer Kommunikation oder so.
Wäre jetzt so mein Verdacht, warum das potenziell eben die Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit
hier geringer ist bei den größeren Stadtzuhöner-Einsätzen.
Wäre jetzt so mein Verdacht.
Diese Fallzahlen wachsen sehr schnell, also es ist doppelt so viel wie im Vorjahr
und das ist also die Statistiken.
Das ist das Erste zum Thema Staatstrojaner. Zweitens gab es zwei Verfassungsbeschwerden,
über die das Bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden hat.
Und das betrifft jetzt den, also einmal das Polizeigesetz NRW,
da gibt es die Befugnis zur Gefahrenabwehr in laufende Kommunikation einzugreifen,
auch über Staatstrojaner.
Da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, das passt so.
Das ist in Ordnung. Gefahren abwählen, laufende Kommunikation eingreifen,
sehen sie keinen Verstoß gegen das Grundgesetz.
Aber in dem Paragraf 100a StPO, Strafprozessordnung.
Da werden geregelt, in dem 100er werden diese ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen und
Eingriffsmaßnahmen geregelt.
Und in dem Paragraf 100a StPO ist eben hier Staatstrojaner und solche Quellenticker
und sowas drin geregelt.
Und da sagen sie, diese Maßnahme, Quellen-TKÜ, die dürfen nicht zur Aufklärung
von Straftaten genutzt werden, die mit einer Höchststrafe von drei Jahren oder
weniger geahndet werden.
Und zwar ist es so, wenn du den 100a StPO anschaust, dann stehen da quasi aufgelistet die Straftaten,
wegen derer ermittelt werden kann mit diesen Mitteln.
Also wann darf man das zum Einsatz bringen? Und dann haben sie eben gesagt,
naja, hier steht, weil das unter anderem auch kleinere Delikte umfasst,
wo das Strafmaß vielleicht so gering ist.
Das muss geregelt werden, dass das eben nicht für Kleinstdelikte zum Einsatz kommen darf.
Und da findet sich diese schöne, in der Pressemitteilung dieser Satz,
mit Blick auf den Strafrahmen einer Strafnorm liegt die besondere Schwere einer
Straftat jedenfalls dann vor,
wenn sie mit einer Höchstfreiheitsstrafe von mehr als fünf Jahren bedroht ist.
Also sagen sie, da fängt eine schwere Straftat an.
Eine besonders schwere. Und sind Straftaten allerdings nur mit einer Höchstfreiheitsstrafe
von bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe
bewährt und damit dem einfachen Kriminalitätsbereich zuzuordnen,
schließt dies die Einordnung als besonders schwere Straftat von vornherein aus.
Und sagen eben, deswegen kann,
also alles, was nur eine, also
sie möchten quasi diesen Ausschluss mit der Höchststrafe, dass sie sagen,
erst wenn es mit mehr als drei Jahren Haft bedroht ist, was hier gerade vorgeworfen
und ermittelt wird, dann darf man auch diese Quellentickerüdern durchführen.
Und dann haben sie noch gesagt, bei der Online-Durchsuchung,
also das ist der 100b-STPO, da sagen sie, der verstößt gegen das Grundgesetz.
Da habe ich gedacht, ja stimmt, natürlich, ich meine, die hacken dein Gerät
und lesen das aus der Ferne aus, aber da sagen sie, nur aus formalen Gründen,
weil in dem Gesetzestext nicht die Grundrechtsbeschränkung ordnungsgemäß im
Gesetzestext zitiert wird.
Und das muss aber zitiert werden und deswegen bleibt das erstmal in Kraft da
müssen sie quasi hinschreiben, dass sie sagen ja hier beschränken wir dann mit
diesem Akt ein Grundrecht.
Also so Straftaten mit mehr als drei Jahren Freiheitsstrafe,
das ist dann halt so Mord, Totschlag, Körperverletzung, Sexualstraftaten, Menschenhandel.
Aber da sind glaube ich, also in dieser Liste, wo du gerade schaust wahrscheinlich,
in dem 100a, da sind halt einige bei, die nicht unbedingt so hohe Höchststrafen haben.
Ich habe einfach mal nur geguckt, was ist denn so ab drei Jahre?
Welche Kategorie erfüllt das?
Und das ist dann halt so Raub, schwerer Raub, Brandstiftung,
Hochverrat, Terrorismus.
Genau, die haben dann hier zum Beispiel...
Also nicht kiffen.
Also sie sagen ja, der Absatz
liest sich schwere Straftaten im Sinne des ersten Absatzes sind und dann listen
sie von A bis V Straftaten auf und da sind eben auch so Dinge wie vorenthalten
und veruntreuen von Arbeitsentgelt.
Und ich vermute, dass in Deutschland vorenthalten und veruntreuen von Arbeitsentgelten
nicht unbedingt eine Höchststrafe von mehr als drei Jahren genast hat.
Sonst würde es hier in diesem Land, glaube ich, etwas anders aussehen.
Also Länder, wo das und das ist glaube ich das, was sie damit meinen.
Raub und Erpressung, Bandendiebstahl. Okay, also das so viel dazu,
das ist jetzt glaube ich keine besonders große Veränderung.
Aber immerhin werden diese Dinge vor Gericht nochmal ausgehandelt,
Weil die Schwellen eben doch sehr gering waren für diesen Einsatz.
Und wo wir schon bei den Verfassungsbeschwerden sind, der Fall Modern Solution,
den wir hier auch regelmäßig im Logbuch Netzpolitik behandelt haben, zur Erinnerung.
Modern Solution, ein Unternehmen, das eine Software so zum Management von Online-Shops oder sowas anbietet.
Also Shop-Plattformen auch irgendwie Kaufland, Otto, Check24 benutzen diese Software.
Und einer der Kunden dieses Unternehmens, Modern Solution,
hatte ein Problem und hat damit zur Belösung dieses Problems einen freiberuflichen,
selbstständigen IT-Experten und Programmierer gebeten, dieses Problem zu lösen.
Weil er das Problem, ein Problem mit dieser Software lösen musste.
Das Unternehmen kommt übrigens aus Gladbeck, die Modern Solution GmbH und Co.
KG, man sollte den Namen relativ oft sagen und der hat sich diese Software angeschaut
und quasi beim Debugging festgestellt, dass das Ding auf eine Datenbank zugreift,
nämlich seinen Datenbank-Servern, also das ist einmal die Applikationskomponente,
die läuft was weiß ich bei dir auf dem Computer und der verbindet sich dann
zu einer Datenbank, die steht da auch, die ist auch von denen und das Passwort,
mit dem der sich bei der Datenbank anmeldet, ist hartgecodet in der Software drin.
Die Konsequenz davon ist, dass überall, wo diese Software ist,
bei egal wem, ob sie jetzt bei Otto, Kaufland, Check24 oder eben diesem Kunden
ist, das Passwort gleich ist.
Und das ist schlecht, weil, ja, das muss man erklären, wenn du jetzt bei dem
einen oder bei dem anderen bist, kannst du eben immer mit diesem Passwort auf
diese Datenbank zugreifen.
Und deswegen macht man ja Passwörter konfigurierbar und hardcoded die nicht.
Diese Schwachstelle hat der Programmierer Modern Solution gemeldet und dann
ein relativ zeitnah auch veröffentlicht.
In einem Blog. Ich habe das Blog leider vergessen, aber das war schon ein bisschen nah dran.
Die Reaktion war, Modern Solution hat den angezeigt und die Polizei hat seine Wohnung besucht,
sein Arbeitsgerät beschlagnahmt und dann ist er durch mehrere Gerichtsurteile
und er ist jetzt quasi rechtskräftig verurteilt, Denn das Gericht sah es als erwiesen an,
dass sich der Mann strafbar gemacht hat,
als er ein Passwort in der Software seines Kunden ausgelesen hatte,
um Zugriff auf die dazugehörige Datenbank auf den Modern Solution Server zu bekommen.
Also nicht, weil der die Sicherheitslücke über das Blog veröffentlicht hat oder
so, sondern schon, dass er gesagt hat, alles klar, ich debugge mal hier dieses Ding,
wo ist die Konfigurationsdatei, sag mal das Passwort von der Datenbankkunde,
sagt, habe ich nicht, sagt er, wie hast du nicht.
Guckt nach einer Konfigurationsdatei, findet keine Konfigurationsdatei und dann
hat er wahrscheinlich irgendwie, ich weiß nicht wie man das bei Windows macht,
aber wahrscheinlich hat das Strings auf das Bydery ausgeführt und hat nach SQL,
gesucht und dann stand da wahrscheinlich irgendwo SQL-Passwort oder sowas.
Also so ungefähr auf dem Niveau wird das gewesen. Quasi das,
sagt das Gericht, das war schon ein,
strafbarer Akt und er sagt, er hat das Passwort er hat ja nur den Zugriff auf
die Datenbank gebraucht, um einen Fehler in der Software zu beheben,
die bei seinem Kunden oder bei dem gemeinsamen Kunden zu Problemen führte.
Und er.
Und damit Gericht hat jetzt halt dann gesagt, ja,
denn mit dem Paragraf 202a StGB, also Hackerparagraf im Jahr 2007,
hat der Gesetzgeber ja offensichtlich bezweckt, das Hacken als solches unter Strafe zu stellen.
Und unter diesem Aspekt sei ein Schutz, der nicht für jedermann einfach zum
Gehen ist, ausreichend, um den Straftatbestand zu erfüllen.
Strafe ist Geldstrafe, keine Haftstrafe, der hat jetzt wirklich eine relativ
niedrige Geldstrafe bekommen.
Aber, und das finde ich auch sehr sinnvoll und auch richtig,
oder finde ich gut, dass der Betroffene und eben auch sein Anwalt sagen, Nee,
also ja klar, aber das geht ja hier ums Prinzip, also dieses Urteil kann so
nicht stehen bleiben, weil es eben ein irrsinniges Gesetz ist und wenn das jetzt
durch die Instanzen durch ist, dann müssen wir eben eine Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Und ich würde hoffen, dass diese Verfassungsbeschwerde Erfolg hat,
weil ja erkennbar ist, dass dieser Mann nicht also dass der Fehler war bei Modern Solution.
Die haben eine fahrlässige Schrottsoftware ihren Kunden verkauft mit die ganz
sicher, also ein hart gecodetes Datenbankpasswort ist ein Produktmangel.
Und nicht eine Sicherheitsmaßnahme, die ein böswilliger Hacker absichtlich umgangen hat.
Ja, ich meine in diesem Gesetz ist einfach noch eine sehr, sehr alte sehr,
sehr altes Nichtverständnis der gesamten,
Computerrealitäten drin kodiert ja, also das stammt ja alles noch aus so einer Zeit,
wo man dann so oh, hier, ja die Unternehmen, die tun doch das Beste,
was sie tun können und jetzt kommen da die bösen Hacker und die finden da so
Sachen raus das müssen wir einfach generell verbieten machen wir da so ein Stoppschild
davor, Hacken verboten und dann wird alles gut.
Und das war ja von Anfang an die Kritik an diesem Gesetz, dass eben genau das
so interpretiert werden können.
Und jetzt kommt sozusagen ein anderes Gericht bei der Überprüfung diesem ganzen
Kram zum Schluss so, naja, das Ziel war ja, dass hier Hacken an sich verboten
wird, was halt totaler Unsinn ist,
weil Hacken ist erstmal sowieso mal der falsche Begriff an dieser Stelle,
da muss man schon mal ein bisschen professioneller,
rangehen, sondern hier geht es halt einfach um Sicherheitsüberprüfung von in
India sogar von diesem Unternehmen selber beauftragt waren.
Das ist ja das, was mich so irre macht bei der ganzen Geschichte und das kann
so einfach keinen Bestand haben und ich weiß nicht, mein Bauch sagt mir,
da wird dann das Verfassungsgericht dann vielleicht doch mal ein bisschen,
anders urteilen, aber wir werden es sehen.
Also der hatte, also er wurde verurteilt, dann sind sie in Berufung gegangen,
da hat das Landgericht Aachen die Berufung als unbegründet abgewiesen.
Damit hat eben das erstinstanzliche Urteil Bestand.
Und jetzt ist die Verteidigung in Revision gegangen.
Unterschied zwischen Berufung und Revision ist, in der Revision erfolgt keine
neue Beweisaufnahme, sondern die nehmen quasi den Aktenstand,
Und prüfen, ob die getroffenen Feststellungen der Vorinstanz ungefähr so gehen.
Ob das also verfahrensrechtlich ordnungsgemäß zustande gekommen ist.
Und wenn in der Berufung hättest du sagen können, Leute, ihr habt das nicht
gecheckt, was hier passiert ist.
Und das ist bei einer Revision nicht. Und entsprechend kommt eben die Revision
zu dem Ergebnis, naja klar, wir haben mal geguckt.
Im Gesetz steht, du sollst dich hacken.
Hier steht ja, der hat das gemacht und jetzt scheint es in Ordnung,
können wir nichts dran beanstammen.
Also ja, das ist wirklich ein wichtiges Gerichtsverfahren da und man sollte sich wünschen,
dass diese Verfassungsbeschwerde durchkommt.
Juti, dann,
kommen wir nochmal zum Meta Ach ja.
Der DSA, also Meta ist ja jetzt so richtig beleidigt wegen der ganzen europäischen
Regeln und die haben gesagt, ja also Leute, mit eurem DSA hier,
Digital Services Act der hat nicht praktikable Anforderungen für politische
Werbung deswegen gibt es jetzt
gar keine politische Werbung mehr bei Facebook und alle so ja ok super,
korrekt, cool gibt es nur noch Wurstwerbung.
Jetzt geht es hier nur noch um die Wurst.
Jetzt wirbt nur noch Markus Söder für Würste,
Ich finde es, also ich meine, da könnte man sagen, der hat auf jeden Fall gewirkt,
der Digital Services Act.
Also DSA, würde ich sagen, kann man so machen.
Ich glaube, dass er dachte, dass er damit,
den Politikerinnen einen auswischt und sagt, jetzt könnt ihr euch halt nicht
mehr eine Wahl kaufen, indem ihr über Facebook die Leute manipuliert.
Aber mal schauen, fand ich auf jeden Fall erstmal ganz okay also ist so in Ordnung Ja.
Ich hoffe das gilt nicht nur für Facebook.
Und Insta,
Insta.
Ja gut, also ich hoffe, das gilt nicht nur für Meta.
Sondern das betrifft ja dann vor allem auch X.
Und da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob sich Olle X da so dran halten wird.
Naja, also also die begründet, also Meta begründet das mit den Anforderungen
zur Transparenz bei Werbung und zum Schutz vor ausländischer,
Einmischung. Und Meta sagt eigentlich nur, dass die Transparenzanforderungen
nicht praktikabel sind.
Also die EU hat es nicht verboten, sondern einfach mit Anforderungen versehen,
die Meta sagt, die sind nicht zu erfüllen und deswegen machen wir es gar nicht.
Nicht zu erfüllen im Sinne von, wir wollen nicht sagen, wer uns dafür bezahlt.
Was auch immer der X-Weg wird hier halt sein,
also X wird folgendes machen die sind nicht zu erfüllen deswegen machen wir es nicht fuck you also.
Nicht die Werbung, sondern die Transparenz die Transparenzregel.
Ja ja das wird der X-Way sein das denke ich auch.
Ja der macht das einfach so und dann regen sich alle auf und dann kommen deutsche
Politiker und sagen wir brauchen jetzt auch eine Alternative zu X,
wir müssen die digitale Souveränität Europas sicherstellen.
Wir begründen jetzt unser eigenes Twitter. Bäh.
Ja, genau. Hä, was war denn nicht früher draufgekommen?
Ich kenne da so ein mittelständisches Unternehmen in Unterfranken.
Die können das bestimmt schnell irgendwie.
Die machen Cyberbook jetzt. Super Datenbank Cyberbook machen wir.
So, komm, noch schnell Termine.
Genau.
Mit Musik?
Also, ja.
Ja?
Okay.
Ja, dann...
So, Termine. Also los geht's in, Moment, in Dresden.
In Dresden geht's los. In Dresden ist was los.
In Dresden ist was los. Datenspuren.
Datenspuren. 19. bis 21. September finden die Datenspuren wieder statt.
Im Zentralwerk.
Immer noch in Dresden.
Zentralwerk ist auch immer noch in Dresden. Die Datenspuren,
da ändert sich nichts. Das ist wie festgewachsen.
Wenn beide in Dresden sind, dann können die auch zusammenkommen.
Eintritt ist wie immer frei und das Programm ist auch schon veröffentlicht worden.
Es fängt irgendwie am Freitagabend oder Freitag um 16 Uhr ist Opening und dann
geht es halt das Wochenende so weiter.
Genau, das geht am Freitag noch relativ lange so ein Mono-Track-Programm und
dann mit Musik und so oder nur zwei Säle und am Samstag und am Sonntag bespielen,
wie tatsächlich bis zu fünf Säle.
So, was gibt's noch?
Der 39C3 wurde völlig überraschend angekündigt.
Datum besteht Das geht noch nicht fest.
Nein, natürlich ist der Startpunkt der 27. bis 30.12.
Und das Motto der Veranstaltung, wieder ein, finde ich, ganz gutes, gelungenes Motto.
Der Airgast hat da tatsächlich wieder, ich weiß nicht, wie oft er da jetzt schon ein Treff hatte.
Power Cycles. Power Cycles, genau. System runterfahren, neu starten. Ja,
unter dem Motto läuft das Programm. und mir gibt es erstmal noch nicht so richtig,
zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, weil ich jetzt nicht so etwas für Tickets kaufen könnte
oder so, aber es ist einfach nur die Reassurance auch der Kongress wird zum 39.
Mal stattfinden und der wird ja in Hamburg stattfinden und natürlich im Kongresszentrum,
im TCH in Hamburg im Herzen Hamburgs, wie es da so schön heißt Herzen,
Ja, und das passt man eigentlich auch schon mit unseren Terminankündigungen.
Mehr haben wir nicht anzukündigen.
Den Bonus-Track zur heutigen Sendung könnt ihr euch bei YouTube dann anschauen.
Das ist nämlich ein Video.
Wir können ja einen Track, den wir schon mal bei uns in der Sendung hatten,
nicht ein zweites Mal rangen.
Ja, und wir haben auch Schwierigkeiten, die Videos hier in den Audio-Podcast reinzubekommen.
Esels Albtraum, unsere Vorband von der LMP 500 haben ein,
Musikvideo veröffentlicht von ihrem Song Wir sind Abrissbirne der Volksmusik und das haben sie,
also offen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich darauf reinfalle,
aber am Ende steht, dass das Video mit freundlicher Unterstützung des Lands
Steiermark, also Österreich ist das ja, und des Bundesministeriums für Wohnen,
Kunst, Kultur, Medien und Sport,
unterstützt wurde. Also von denen haben die irgendwie Förderung bekommen für dieses Musikvideo.
Und das finde ich schon ganz schön, wenn sie dafür,
Förderung bekommen haben. Wer ist denn jetzt zum Beispiel Bundes...
In welchen Hand ist denn das Bundesministerium,
für Wohnen und Sport oder was?
Bundesministerium.
Das ist das, also das findet man unter,
bmwkms.gv.at, das Bundesministerium für Wohnen, Kunst, Kultur, Medien und Sport.
Und wer ist da der zuständige Minister oder Ministerin? Bestimmt Minister, oder?
Da steht erstmal sehr viel zu nah. Andreas Babler, das ist der Vizekanzler.
Und wer ist der Kanzler? Das Ministerium hat einen Kanzler?
Ja, auf jeden Fall Steiermark hat einen Landeshauptmann von der FPÖ.
Das darauf wollte ich noch.
Ja, Bund ist ja gerade nicht FPÖ. Da sind sie ja nochmal dran vorbeigekommen.
Das folgt dem nicht mehr in Österreich, das geht mir ja da zu schnell.
Das konnte ja gerade noch auf den letzten Metern verhindert.
Okay, also dann ist die, dann das Land Steiermark und die FPÖ haben dieses schöne,
antikapitalistische und antifaschistische Jodel Video gesponsert,
welches auch lustig anzuschauen ist.
Ja, das ist auch schön. Ich meine Jodeln, das haben wir ja dann auch bei LNP
500 im Interview dann auch gelernt, ist halt auch eine Ausdrucksform. Ja, schon Widerstands.
Ja.
Jo Leute, das war's. Wir sind wieder am Start und hören uns auch bald wieder,
aber damit müssen wir jetzt erstmal zurechtkommen.
Wir hören uns dann bald wieder.
Und lass das fetischhafte Wurst gefressen bleiben.
Das geht gar nicht.
Echt, ey.
Ciao, ciao.